welcome
too much energy or do you like it
everybody
i'm just tired because that was our
second take and i was like uh
why do you say it's our second take i
don't want people to know that we're
doing multiple takes out no you don't i
like i like transparency
you but that's like the sauce like you
don't want people to know how the
sausage is made that's not transparency
you're
volunteering too much information my
energy is low though because we already
need to take one and my energy was good
okay first of all our first take was
like 30 seconds
and i dropped that f-bomb in the first
30 seconds which gets your video
demonetized so we're like oh let's just
do it again so it wasn't like
you were running a mile in that first 30
seconds i was pretty on point and i'm
like
a little discomfort oh my god
so here let's relive those first you
were saying that um
that you see some comments of people
saying the stick is getting old
yeah they're just like i'm over this
it's like it's boring now nobody says
that
i've seen a couple comments i'll
screenshot them why do you dig so deep
looking for
like we are a cultural tour de force do
you understand
if somebody comes to my comments and
says this just getting old i will block
you
i will ban you i will not even think
about it twice
and if i see you in real life you better
better hope i don't know that you're the
guy that said wrote that
you don't even leave your house exactly
so who are you gonna see low risk
that's why you're so tough like last
week when you're like bryce hoff i see
you like you're just tough because you
don't oh yeah
i'll never run into bryce all right yeah
wait didn't he dm you what the [ __ ]
yeah what did he say wait bryce so we
did douchebag of the month with bryce
hall
and he dm'd you why did he do we want to
say why we're dressed like this
or the sponsors oh sponsored god that's
the best.com sponsoring today's use code
h3
happy 5th 50th uh birthday to adam and
eve march is their 50th birthday yeah we
can talk about it later in that area but
yes it's
50 years so you know they're good and
our other sponsor is
honey that's two sponsors
um look at us look at us look at us baby
sponsor a tick tock because there's a
popular shot going around it's like
honey honey
how you thrill me oh that's a good idea
you want to see if they like
i'll i'll see i mean i don't know
they'll be like what
i'm like yo there's this popular tick
tock where you go honey honey
how you doing uh-huh and that's it
that's the whole thing
so what would you do just put like the
honey logo or something and just see
what
what in the huh is the punchline part so
the the punch line you put like the disc
the code h3 or whatever it is
it's like i don't like it
it's all about uh branding and mercedes
sounds like a lot british jealous
okay why are we wasting all of our time
talking about this [ __ ]
or first of all there is not [ __ ] i
think okay
we love them but like even honey check
them out yeah bad reads later on in the
show
yeah okay okay okay okay it's like it's
not that adam and eve and honey
show oh well i'm making it that so we
can get it back we do love them though
we're just like there's so much going on
today today
is the episode you will not want to miss
are you going to say why we're just like
this or no
well first of all let me say david
dobrik
extreme update extreme
updates do i know about this i think you
do it's that lit the video that one of
his fans posted
for some [ __ ] reason they dug deep
into the david archives and posted a
video of him
and jason talking about the seth
situation
i saw that so that was shocking no
literally just like a recap like there
were videos them and just like literally
admitting that it's gonna ruin his life
for a couple of years
and also that it was racially motivated
yeah yeah i i saw that
that racially related because of where
he was from they risk he's from compton
so this is even worse that we're doing
it to him
he's or anyway we'll get into that and
then
james charles is in honestly this guy
needs to be
just like ah i don't want to i don't
want to go too over the top but
like if we could just get james charles
in a hole like saddam hussein or
something then
then i think the world would be safer
how come he doesn't have to be
registered as
an so exactly you know what i mean like
that's what i'm saying we just got to
put him in a [ __ ] ditch like saddam
hussein and
just just forget about it the thing is
is like okay we're going to write
war crimes against humanity is what i'm
saying but he's like done so many times
so he needs like a label so people know
he's like a danger to
kids society and i totally agree he need
like if he moves into a new neighborhood
he definitely needs to introduce himself
as like hi i'm the so
or even like brand deals he should
always have to say i am this
because you're marketing on tick tock
his best friend is a 16 year old and
it's like you're marketing yourself to a
16 year old for a reason
so what well anyway james so another
person outed james
for exchanging nudes with a 16 year old
uh there's been a local one since then
there's exactly like three or four since
then
and he admitted it james was like yeah
he he
didn't come his age i guess he should
have asked what it's all here
this is the biggest baddest
steamiest episode of all time was there
more or no that's it that's the drama
well there's a lot more here i want to
get to but for our costumes okay
are free britney go ahead treasure is
that why
i don't know okay i think it was your
idea it was not my idea let me just say
this because we were gonna be like oh
wow jesus wants to be a couple's costume
with ethan first of all not my idea to
do this
love it i'm so down i love dressing in
costume and honestly i've always wanted
to wear these outfits
whose idea was this i think it was elas
which i lost
i honestly live and i was like okay
don't put this on me because everyone's
gonna be like oh
okay yeah so here's the big reveal
the whole thing was i was wondering if i
could get those justin timberla
lake or timberland i'm not even kidding
we're like yeah timberlake
what's a timber like tim berlin is a
thing
it really doesn't need i literally went
my entire life thinking his name was
timber
timberland okay first of all yeah okay
i don't know which came first like the
chicken and the egg thing i don't know
if it's like you were talking about his
ramen hair on your h3 podcast
or these outfits i'm not really sure
right
because i know you guys were talking
about his hair yeah he had ramen hair
right and that was recent so i don't
really know what came first but i was um
can you show his ramen here dan cause i
feel like i didn't even achieve what he
hasn't
my the only conclusion i can have about
him is that
he actually permed his hair he must have
had tiny little curlers in his [ __ ]
hair
he had really curly hair if you grew
your hair out would be curly i don't
think so i think he's out there perming
his hair like he obviously cares about
his look so he's permed look at his hair
now it's not that curly
is it well it's short he has like a buzz
cut
yeah should we have him on the show as a
guest i don't see any problem with that
you think he can won definitely this
show i think he would because he's
really big into like snl and jimmy
fallon like he likes to be comedic
right like us we're snl i had a dream
that i was hosting so now i think it's
going to come to fruition oh my god
i'd watch it oh thank you you think it
happened no
no i think it might so what's your path
to be hosting nsl i'm curious
yeah this show holy [ __ ] it's my biggest
thing i have going for you wait
how can this show could this show ain't
lean you to nsa
snl maybe the nfl the only the only
place this show's leading you is [ __ ]
i think it's going to lead me to i don't
know
as a host they mentioned youtubers who
didn't mention last week they mentioned
youtuber sometimes
jake paul logan paul i'm right up there
all right so but i love this hair and i
also heard that you actually bleached
your hair before for like a boy band
video i heard this from my h3 expert
over there
yeah so you i think low-key secretly
deep down maybe you want to be a boy
bander
you went spray tan last time you're
bleaching your hair i think maybe you
like this aesthetic you're down for it
it's not just a gag it's like you like
it well that's like saying i want to
look like uncle fester i mean
i i'm willing to do it for the joke for
the gag yeah that's like halloween time
i i don't think it looks bad i mean i i
think i'm too old to walk around looking
like this it's embarrassing but
then again i also have a rolls-royce and
that's embarrassing too so who cares
let's just [ __ ] go all the way up
in front of your rolls-royce you look
like a mid-life crisis bro can you
imagine
yeah exactly it fits the bill i love it
by the way i love my roles right
somebody somebody recognized me in it
they looked over and they're like oh
it's ethan and i was like oh you so you
know about my new car
she's like yeah no people who gag for it
because when it's a rolls-royce so
anyone's just gonna look because it's a
rolls-royce because those are cool cars
i always do
do you look out at people to be like
what's up [ __ ] i try not to i try and
like just because it after a while it
gets to be like a lot but um
but it is cool like what it's like
people who like like our show or like
like me or whatever it's cool
but so whenever anyone sees a pink or
black rolls royce on the road you better
there's a good chance if you're in l.a
it's going to be me
do you roll down the window you give a
thumbs up or you're like hey what do you
do
i keep my eyes i don't think many people
look the block is really discreet it's
not like the pink one
right the pink is a lot pink is so much
i know this weekend again we were
sitting in the portillo's parking lot
eating french fries and hamburgers
and this girl like knocks on my window
to take a picture with me and i'm like
oh
just wait till i'm done knocks on the
window what it was so many times
this weekend was a lot we tried what are
they the police i mean who knocks on the
window like what is this so then when i
said
not right now because i was just like
overwhelmed because like i don't know i
just like
we already had a day i had a panic
attack earlier that day at disneyland
and we didn't go to disneyland we were
like one minute in and i was like bye
because like the lines just to get in
we're into too many people well we would
go before you did you have to pay
no we didn't this was like the party i
heard they were gonna pay they're
charging people seventy five dollars for
the privilege
just walking around empty no ride
disneyland disney it opens
yeah i'll say anyways
a touch of disney
touching touching my wallet if you don't
have a mask don't also ask
someone didn't have a mask on and they
moses was pumping the gas and i was
sitting in the car and i can have a
picture with her and he noticed that she
had a mask he's like maybe not without
the mask because the coved
so just don't you know wait we like the
hair i like that
you want the hat on okay yeah um
why are you having panic attacks what's
going on with you because i never do i'm
like i'm literally not a panic attack
person at all like i don't even know
what they are until someone's like
that's a panic attack but
um we were at disneyland because like
usually we can just like walk in and
just like
shop and like get out or like get food
and go out or something and that's what
we're gonna do and there were so many
lines like i swear there was one
probably 300 people just lining up
sneaking in the parking lot i'm just not
a lime person period
okay but also covered and just like
everything i was just like oh my god so
we just started just walking from our
car to the the parking lot where the
line was
is there anything people coming up to
which again i like i was just feeling
like overwhelmed because when you're
sitting there in line
you're like a sitting duck right you're
like a target so people are gonna just
come up which is
again fine but the problem is our
postmate did this the other day too
when people were like okay i didn't
picture sure
okay you're at my house it's a little
inappropriate but okay and then you know
then he's like can i have a video shout
out i was like okay cool i'll do a video
cameo wait wait wait wait then he's like
video shout out pay me
my cameo rate is a thousand dollars he
just gave me a hot pizza in the past and
everything and i'm doing all this stuff
for him and then he's like wait can i
get my sister on the phone real quick
oh get out get the [ __ ] out
okay then like i just i have to start
saying no because that's what's
happening in disneyland so when people
want me to like these people call people
i'm just like i don't want to hold your
phone because i cover it it's just like
a lot
and i'm not ungrateful because like
literally i know i'm like nobody without
anybody watching me like i'm so
appreciative of it but like
don't like ask for five thousand things
like a phone call a video shot like i'll
do a picture and a video shout out but
damn like you said it's like a cameo i
don't even do cameo and
like me i don't even like doing it first
of all why are you meeting your
postmates at the door
i usually don't this was when we were at
my old house we were getting the last of
my stuff
and moses was upstairs and i was like
let me just grab the postman i usually
don't leave it and go
oh you haven't leave at the door i'll
[ __ ] usually moses gets it no no no why
what is this that's over i love this new
year
this is over we don't meet at the
postmates did yourself in the viewfinder
no i was like you weren't looking
i was looking right at moses for some
reason no i see your eyeballs i see your
eyeballs now
here i'll do this so you can see always
where i'm looking at to make sure i'm
not you look cool
no i always like myself you look
actually so close what is this with the
po
this is to this is over the handshaking
the postmates
why do you need to give me the food even
if the door
leaves oh you would have really flipped
out someone's like hey can we do a photo
without why do you why do you meet the
postmates
but why just leave leave the food leave
the [ __ ] food and leave
your job is done there's no interaction
required
you know wherever the food ends up then
god bless it
anyways um yeah it's like it's cool it's
whatever
you're like can we take our masks off
and make out for a photo people
literally do that like can we take our
mess down i'm like
no i'm like and you know what i tell
them i'm like you know what ethan's
really apparently about covet i don't
want to go monday again
that's fine you're right no you're
really my main company i should do i
should split blame it on you
bro i never oh when someone tries to
take a photo sorry trisha says i can't
they'll be like what stupid um
yeah no anyways it's cool i love it that
day i was having a panic attack and then
the people at my car what do you feel
when you have a panic attack i don't
know it literally because we took it it
took us a long time just like two hours
because of the traffic to get down to
anaheim and
so i was like alright and then i was
like feeling like oh i don't want to
like turn around because you know
moses drove all this way with me and i
don't want to turn around and i was like
oh i want to get inside i said oh so i
was just like conflicting things and all
of a sudden it was like caving in on me
like the whole world so when people were
coming up to me
it really felt like the world was like
caving in and i'm like we gotta go we
gotta go so when we were like running i
like ran like through the bushes of
disneyland like parking lot because i
was like so
freaking out were you running after did
you know what was happening you led the
way
he's my body would you are you throwing
elbows and [ __ ] i imagine like there's
hordes of people coming at trisha
moe is just throwing elbows sounds
awesome kind of
yeah moses is really good he's really
good even like that one girl that wanted
to take a picture with me they asked
moses for a picture with me first of all
you can ask me for a picture
i love that people ask moses for photos
like he's your caretaker
moses you need to do a uh
conservatorship on her ass
he probably will yeah you need you need
to it for her
yeah well you know that's pretty good as
my lawyer said
that he has they asked me if he's a
valuable asset when we were talking
about like marriage details and stuff
they're like well is he a valuable asset
wait what what does that mean yeah like
when we're because both of us have like
our own things for like prenups and
stuff like that
you guys are doing a prenup and probably
something anyways oh interesting but
are you worried he's a gold digger no
but also he has property without me like
you know it's our own thing but you guys
are doing a prenup this is great
but look first of all it's totally fair
because honestly and my lawyer did ask
me she's like
oh do you consider him like a valuable
asset to you i was like yeah
because there's a couple options like
you like anyway i don't want to go no
this is fascinating what does that mean
how can you
label a person of valuables so he really
is i told him this the other day i was
like because he just does like he
literally if we were ever to like
divorce right we get married divorced
like i'd probably still keep i'd
probably like pay him to keep doing the
stuff that he's doing for me now you
know what i mean without it
no because he does i'm i'm just doing
that i believe that he's very that he is
a very
helpful and per and very integrated to
life but if you guys got divorced his
house would be [ __ ] grounded to
bone though wait no i don't think so you
know what he said we have this oh god
can i say this oh i'll say whatever
last night because you're talking about
i'm like you're going to like leave me
and then what am i going to do because i
want to be able to take care of the
house i wouldn't you know what i mean
whatever
and i was like and you know what it's
cause you're going to be cheating on me
he's like no you're going to be the one
that's going to cheat on me he thinks
i'm the one that's going to cheat
exactly but moses not that i think he
will but you know temptation happens
with guys
from what i know about moses
moses is a little bit of an enigma on
that i don't think moses is a
is a cheater you wouldn't i know but
that's always the ones you unassume the
ones that you don't assume
that's not true i feel like it's usually
the obvious ones
where it happens well i feel like that's
totally not true
i don't think we'll ever divorce i
really don't think that but just in case
that's interesting but um
yeah but i do consider him like he is
he's probably my most valuable asset
like he's like an advisor like he is
he's like a conservative
advisor father everything he does
everything
stop he's literally doing my whole mom's
move like it's
and i'm like you don't have to do that
like i'll do it like whatever like he
does he's just moving her completely
like
is your full-time job at this point
moses just taking care of all trish's
[ __ ]
sounds like it yeah yeah but she's like
my mom
and my again no but he just does it he's
just
very helpful no he literally just does
all the calls like he's
like today we forgot your outfit
upstairs and i was like i'm low energy
and he's like i'll go get it
but like i don't know moses is the best
i agree look my whole life
i mean i've known moses for a long time
he's always been one of the most
gracious helpful
generous with his time and energy people
there yeah i was like crying this
morning because
he went to go inside to go get my
starbucks opportunity because i was
having a little bit of a low energy
morning this morning actually i don't
really feel that well whatever not well
but just like little energy i felt
and he like went inside and got me a
starbucks and the cake pop
and i just i like crying i was like i
love you so much like that so it was so
nice because we were like a little late
but he's like you know what we'll just
do the little starbucks thing
and he lets me wait in the car so i have
to put a mask on with through my makeup
and then he gets my
drink pop i feel great now and i feel so
much better
that's a true love story he always oh he
brought me pie in bed the other morning
i was like oh my god thank you okay here
uh now i'm
i knew you were a feeder bro i knew you
were a feeder
you were just saying that you were going
to start the diet yeah the diet didn't
work it lasted a day remember i did keto
for a day and i was so depressed
dude the first day is the hardest i was
so sad i just wanted pasta
and we ordered um we had we had steak
and asparagus and i was like
i just want pasta that's all i had all
day i was so sad i was like i can't do
this so then i wanted an opposite
campaign of you i went on the i'm happy
and fat just be yeah
i noticed that i felt really bad i felt
really bad after that last episode not
because of you but because i was just
like
oh my god i literally don't have a
willpower if you're happy and
if you're happy and fat go god bless
yeah good but then like last week i felt
like maybe i should dye it too but then
i was like no i'm more miserable on a
diet
like do whatever you feel my thing is i
feel you
i i constantly feel like i'm losing a
war
of self-will like i'm like i want to
lose weight so bad
and the fact that i'm failing to every
day it's not even about losing the
weight so much as it is about like
having not having that control and
feeling like every night when i go to
bed thinking about
i [ __ ] up and had another shitty food
day and i'm just such a [ __ ] loser i
feel like i get triggered now because
now i'm starting to feel that way i'm
like you're right i'm so gross too like
no no it's just my personal experience
with my issues but
dude i [ __ ] trust me i i wish
bro i wish no you're doing so good
because you're eating the meat and
you're still doing good and i was like
oh that's so
and i know you're gonna lose like a [ __ ]
like i know you will oh and i'll be
jealous i'm not moving
anyway and it's been like two weeks and
all i want is the
what would i eat right now maybe
maybe we should skip this because it's
hard to watch like you talk about this
on every podcast about the yeah we have
so much to talk about
do you want to bring those do you want
the food dan wait what
what are you eating so you two didn't
you instagram me some [ __ ] photo of
some weird like
[ __ ]
no really so
trisha of course posted this weird ass
photo of like peeps
driving a car and so
of course we we did it custom made by
ian and his girlfriend sam these are us
and our rolls-royces
these are us and our rolls-royces the
peeps
yeah i don't know if you get here maybe
can you bring it close to the camera
yeah i mean it's pretty epic these are
amazing i can't eat it i'm just
that i'm so sad that i can't eat this oh
my god but can you
these are so [ __ ] cool oh my god so
that's us in our rolls royces
so you can tell me if it's good oh my
god we oh my god this is so okay
wow i wish like she's not on keto eat
all the sugar honestly i need this
because the sugar cake pop helped me you
posted it look i'm here
you put you posted the photos i'll show
you this real quick
today before i dig in are you okay
you're gonna do a tick tock in the
middle of the show
okay go ahead sorry go ahead no problem
okay can i just do my first bite because
that's what i do on tick-tock
absolutely yeah what i eat in a day a
pee a rolls-royce driving peep
this is so exciting okay okay
oh my gosh so what is this
what is the premise of this one a fat
happy girl who's not trying to lose
weight
yeah okay that's what i figured they
helped people
i want to be a fat happy guy who's not
trying to lose weight you're gonna look
so bomb
look at this look at these hap these
people are so [ __ ] happy
and they're chocolate covered rolls
right these [ __ ]
first of all how did they do this how do
they do the twinkie
it looks like they just oh no that's
chocolate
can i say i swear i was like thinking
like oh i hope maybe i should bring this
to like make on friend of these next
week but like
i just posted a picture because i
thought it was cute and then i thought
like you know we did it
you know we were questioning never in a
million years did i think you'd do it
like honestly i posted it because i was
like
it'd be fun to make it in front of me
let me just like post it whatever and
then like to have them already made
because i hate making [ __ ] like this is
already great
well thank you to sam and ian what
should we do do they have like should we
give them extra shout out should they
you want to replace my link with their
link first of all
first of all ian works for me so calm
down i do pay him well tell them they
can have
whatever link they want i'm trying to
replace a mine this week this is so
okay link is life links are live
trish is like the currency of the future
is lynx
this is a nice how is it it's so good
okay i think
good oh my god all right that's so nice
wow
let's get to the juice oh my god thank
you
hey you're more than welcome we want to
make you feel comfortable we'd like to
accommodate in any way we possible
i mean we're competing against moses
here who's like you know the most
accommodating person in the planet so
we're doing what we can oh my god no
seriously this is a nice thing like
literally anyone's ever done for me
besides what moses said sorry moses
wow okay before we talk about david and
james i have to ask you first of all
there's a
few you getting this dan okay so trisha
this i gotta ask you about this was
cracking
i was watching this and i couldn't stop
[ __ ] laughing and i'll tell you why
here i think you love my posture
so so what i was expecting to happen is
be like oh [ __ ] i gotta restart
but you didn't restart restart the pasta
or the video
wait was that water is that that's
actually how there's pasta in there
and then you ate that yeah it was salty
that night oh yeah
oh stop he didn't like it he didn't you
just dumped like half a cup of salt in
there
i was expecting you to be like oh [ __ ] i
gotta start over it's ruined
but you kept going soldiering on i was
like no you can't eat that
look you like oh no big deal
i could not believe what i was saying
it's really good and by the way there's
not that much pasta in there i can see
it's not that full
i made a whole box of pasta it's all the
gorilla in there
girl that was a lot of the water back in
that's my famous butter noodles that i
always told you about that i make them
really good
like for the pasta water i babish baking
with babish
that looked like a lot of salt well it
didn't taste that bad because it boiled
salt doesn't boil out salt does not boil
out
yes it does salt stains okay i believe
because honestly i don't know but as
things reduce they get saltier
and get your pasta out okay anyway that
was cracking me up i was like oh my gosh
she actually ate it i watched your
industry podcast you guys mentioned my
videos in there now and i love it i was
like thank you
okay treasure the other thing i have to
ask you about this [ __ ]
i die okay somebody sent me a photo of
this and i was like i can't believe this
is real so i went to your channel
to confirm if it was real or not and
sure as [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is your thumbnail
i don't know what happened i don't know
what happened
i was like this is this is actually her
oh yeah go to trisha's channel
james charles is sick in the head and
this is the [ __ ] thumbnail that's
what youtube picked for me
i don't know how that happened i
couldn't believe it
i thought someone was [ __ ] with me
and then sure enough here let's go to
trisha's channel
which channels on because you have like
20 channels i get confused
is it still that yes no what
i changed it that's your thing about
that
no oh you did fix it here i see it now
sometimes
last night that's what it was it was
just on my [ __ ] it was just on my
homepage that is so weird that's so
funny
oh my god that was the funniest thing
ever that was so frustrating because we
were at my house moving the other stuff
over and the james charles stuff was
happening and you guys were talking
about it live on each tree and i was
like i gotta get home and make a video
it was so sad dude you have the best
little moments you're
my favorite youtuber straight up okay
i'll put it out there with the salt and
the thumbnails
are you saying that like in a mean way
i wouldn't call it it's not mean
no no it's complete flatter i love how
you just [ __ ] you are the epitome of
youtube you go for it if you look like
you're
melting into a satanic primordial soup
you go with it like my face like what
the thought what like i look like i'm
melting into it no the thumbnail looked
like that oh yeah but i didn't choose
that so you can't give me credit no but
you you
but you
youtube gives you like three options
just pick a different one man that's
awesome oh well thank you
i know i i appreciate you that you
appreciate my content
yeah i feel like i've been so underrated
not to like do my own horns but how come
i've never like popped off
which in a way is good because i've
never been able to be fully canceled
because i know people only famous people
love you you have like a huge fan base
can you men can you get this [ __ ]
grubhub ad like if you want to sponsor
me go for
[ __ ] get so pissed at youtube ads
thank you for
supporting my whole life congratulations
on your weight loss and like keeping
with the diet i haven't lost any weight
no but you've been keeping on on a diet
and i feel like you feel better weeks
and look at this
it looks like look at me i'm like
i heard you're in an accident you've
been two weeks it's been like a week
that's hey and diet world that's like 10
years
well we're gonna do a weigh-in on
thursday so you don't want to miss
ethan's big weigh-in
riveting so anyway here's the other is
this jewish
oh no it's a [ __ ] napkin how could a
napkin be jewish i thought it was like a
passover napkin
oh wait what no
who should we talk about that no your
the mom thing
what about your mom no your mom what
about my mom kaiser should we edit it
out
say it say it say it she texted me she's
just it's cute it's sweet
she texted moses that what did she talk
to she said something like about what
was the initial reason she texted you
don't say the whole thing what was the
initial reason
she was just congratulated oh yeah she
said
something and then she goes and also i
don't hate trisha i don't know where
that came from we disagree on things but
like i don't hate her and i was like so
random
so nice though i saw my my so theodore
was with my parents this weekend um
and i was by the way she brought it up
she's like i don't want trisha to think
that i hate her like i want to
but you told me she hates me that's why
i thought that
you literally said out in front of me
and my mom hates you oh she said for on
things about you
i mean peace and love i'm just being
honest nobody does hate me
no she was just mad at the moment you
should understand that as much as anyone
for sure she has not held on to that she
would have never come over for another
holiday ever again because i literally
like [ __ ] on your sister
no no they'll be happy to see him there
i think i was trying to be competitive
at the beginning in front of me so i was
like oh [ __ ] your family like i don't
know
no but but it's not like that i don't
know why i say the things i say
sometimes sometimes i just like i
i don't know we also made fun of this
valenciaga shirt
on our last episode of the podcast and
then everyone's like dude trisha bought
that shirt
the balenciaga first of all that shirt
was actually cool
really i think where is it now where is
it now
i think it's in my closet really yeah i
almost brought it today
i thought about wearing it over this
yeah you should next time because i want
to inspect it i thought we're being
jewish next time
right we are there's i like
do you have two hangers in it is it
hanging on two hangers or one
i don't know oh no there's two hangers i
think that came like that with one side
i think they gave me two hangers oh my
god a chocolate pretzel bottom
do you think this was worth thirteen
hundred dollars
um the shirt yeah yeah i think because
it's once i got it it was like a
one-of-a-kind item
what's that one of a kind well it's
unique in the fact that they haven't
recreated it
okay all right are you just a hater
because it's not teddy fresh
no i like i no i just think it's a funny
shirt
okay that's it that's all the stuff i
had that i wanted to talk about
i didn't know that i would have gathered
something to talk to you about
why i can't think you're welcome to i
mean hey like you always say this is
yourself
yeah i do i think you're fat phobic
okay drawer balls
what does that mean that i don't like
fat people i think you have a fear of
fat people like you don't like people
fear yeah what does that mean like a
coward away from fat people
not i'm not i'll again with first people
love like with peace and love like last
episode you're like oh like you did a
either a slip or a freudian slip or
whatever
where you were like oh you need to lose
some weight now that you need to lose
some weight you we should compete and
lose weight like you said something
along those lines
i only said that because i know based on
all the conversation we have
that you expressed to me that you
want to lose weight i would love to be
skinny but i'm also just happy and i
don't really care about losing weight
and i'm happy well give me a hundred
pounds and i'll take it okay
but i don't want to do the work okay
right meanwhile i was happy and cool
but then after that update you're
rewriting history
because no way because back then we were
like we're losing weight together and
now you're like i'm happy and i
was very excited about it i was pumped
you're like now i'm happy and fat and so
now i'm
upset about what you said when you
wanted to because then no it's not fair
on that tuesday all the comments are
like you guys don't look bad so i texted
you i'm like oh you know what comments
are saying we don't look that fat and
you're like they're lying
yeah i'm kidding i mean i'm kidding but
you know people always say that they
tell you what you want to hear in the
comments i was like i think i love that
phobic because i was like you know what
we don't look that bad
like they're lying i was kidding no you
didn't say lol
you should need to do whatever did you
think that was the point indicators you
need to give me a tone indicator when
you text me now
what should i say like imprints she's
like
oh for real yeah is that a thing yeah
tone indicator
what is what if s means serious
backslash i'm dead serious that's not
what it means
you just need a little tone indicator if
you're gonna make those kind of jokes
okay geez i think you're a friend
it's okay peace and love like it's fine
if you're fat phobic and it's totally
because a lot of people are
because you know why you weren't fat
when i looked at you someone put
together like our high school photos
which
so weird can i tell you something so on
and i know dan has
like said oh are you on reddit i'm sure
i'm not on reddit because i don't i
literally don't know how to access it
but
moses goes checks throughout it anyways
friday morning i was like in bed and i
was like looking for high school
pictures from my tic toc and i was like
i wonder what ethan looked like in high
school so i like googled you
and then that day like it was like did
you post this on reddit i was like what
no and it was literally like our high
school pictures and i had saved all your
photos in my phone that morning and then
it was on reddit
like that afternoon who's mine and yours
yours because i was yeah i always show
up there
like periodically they show up there but
that was weird because i never i've
never searched for your high school
photos i don't know like
most probably like why are you taking
photos like ethan in high school cause i
was just saving on my phone because oh
it's kind of funny i don't know bringing
up whatever
if anything you're skinny obsessed
you've admit that i'm totally skinny
obsessed but it doesn't mean i'm fat
phobic well i don't think i'm that
[ __ ] that obsessed like i love being
like fat sometimes like i love the way
my belly looks like
emotion on camera really see i don't
like that all right not on you but
sometimes when i'm in the mirror i'll
and i'm naked i
lean over and like you it's just like a
whole alien creature and i grab it and i
go
oh this is i love it though while i'm
not sexually attracted to big bellies
like i
am so attracted to big bellies like
they're so fun and fascinating to like
look at
i hate them and i kind of like it do i
mean yeah i'm fatphobic okay i'm
fatphobic
i'm fatphobic i think you're a little
aphobic i don't think it's your fault i
think but i don't know it's skinny
and you never had like a weight problem
and stuff like that so i don't think you
know my parents are definitely fat
phobic
i feel like old people like don't like
so that makes sense
they have like this whole thing of like
fat people are just lazy and dumb and
stuff
right i think that's in your head that's
what you think like you you even said it
yourself like you
oh if you at night you're like i lack
willpower or self-control or whatever
when you but that's true if you really
want to get something done and you keep
failing to do it then it's
self-defeating i've starved myself for
literally like
30 days straight and i lost 30 pounds in
a month and i could document it i did a
walk
for you i can't do that no the point is
is like that doesn't i'm a fat person
doesn't mean i don't have willpower i'm
talking about myself
not all fat people i'm talking about
myself that's true though when i was
saying that oh fat people like you know
don't lack the willpower or they're lazy
that's not true
no i'm just saying i'm not saying it's
true i'm saying that's like the
stereotype that people have like all a
lot especially old people have
it's fat phobic i agree it's fatphobic
but i don't believe that
what exactly what that people who are
fat
are is i feel like being fat and a lot
of times is from
stems from like addiction problems
oh my god addiction mental health
disorders coping mechanisms
physical like metabolism you know what i
started myself so much as a kid that my
metabolism true story and i'm not just a
fat person like metabolism doesn't work
like literally my metabolism is so
freaking slow that if i do actually try
to diet like it's so
hard for me to lose weight that's why i
have to fast to lose weight because like
it just doesn't work if i eat i'll
wear a true story because i used to like
starve myself as a kid for like a week
at a time and then a week i'd binge and
then it literally [ __ ] up my like i
have gastrointestinal bleeding because
of it like it just [ __ ] me up so much
and it is a physical thing and yes i've
always been fat but like that is the
main reason why i continue to be fat
and we haven't tried something though i
love exercising
well you kicked my ass in the physical
competition so who am i
but like yeah being being fat sucks
because first of all
if any other addiction you can hide
nobody judge you everywhere you go
and second of all you don't need [ __ ]
let's say heroin to survive
you have to eat food to live so that's
what makes the food addiction even
harder it's like
you can't just go cold turkey on it you
gotta [ __ ] eat
and on top of it it's so stressful to
carry around the weight because
everybody can say oh look at this fat
[ __ ] and judge you and everything you
know i mean
being being fat is very it's very hard
it's very
it's very hard we should also clarify
too i think because i i got a few
messages and i relate to this as well
when my sister calls
herself out which again everyone has the
right to feel fat or whatever you want
to lose weight
but if we call ourselves like fat right
and then like there's people bigger than
us that think like oh my god if you're
fat then i must be like the disgusting
piece of [ __ ] you know what i mean like
it like it kind of sounds like the wrong
message i don't think we're like hold on
but we have to all i do think it's
important that we acknowledge
that while you have every right to be
fat and happy and make your own life
choices it is not healthy to be fat
neither is skinny sometimes though
skinny's not always healthy yo that's
what i'm not talking about skinny people
but that's like saying everybody's gonna
be unhealthy it doesn't matter if you're
fat skinny it doesn't matter everyone's
unhealthy like everyone makes unhealthy
decisions
why is being fat any different than like
not eating enough food i'm not saying it
is you're you're you're you're shifting
the arkansas do you think being in keto
is healthy no i don't
so what is your point that helps no
because there's
this movement oh there's a movement to
be like i can be
health like the healthy at any size
that's not a movement it's beautiful at
any size there's nothing beautiful at
any size i agree with you
and you can be healthy at any size that
i disagree with okay let's we should get
our cholesterol check i have low
i have low cholesterol i have low blood
pressure i get it checked all the time
like
in general extra weight
is associated with ton
i'm not saying this is healthy that's
healthy i'm just saying we want to act
like being fat is like
it's it's very unhealthy to be fat
that's like but that's anything anyone's
doing like it's unhealthy to do they're
so
i agree if you drink you're gonna have
like you're gonna die of liver disease
like there's just so many things that
make you unhealthy but you're
specifically targeting fat people
like what it isn't healthy it's
unhealthy to be [ __ ] skinny it's
unhealthy to be a smoker it's unhealthy
to be like
are in parties right now smoking weed
for your lungs drinking alcohol there's
so many things but you're specifically
talking fat people why
because targeted enough we all speak i
love we as a community
yeah you're right speaking on their
rehab no i'm part of the fat community
now you're not though
you're not even fat i'm part of that i
am fat as a
as a representative of the fat community
you have a belly it's not fat you're not
bad anywhere else there's no fatness to
you
listen that's the only thing but
everyone has a belly when they eat moses
has a belly when he eats and he's like
180. moses is a healthy weight i'm fat
dude but he also eats me so why do i
point out why am i specifically saying
being overweight is unhealthy it's
because everybody
except the premise that smoking and
drinking
and like being anorexic or whatever is
is very unhealthy
but fat people there's this like there's
i feel like there's this kind of like
collective weird kind of like i'm
there's like this collective delusion
that you can be healthy and fat and it's
not true
that no one's saying that no i don't
okay so so then holiday is like
i'm so freaking healthy she does do i
say that all i say is
no you don't you're real you're real
tess holliday thinks she's healthy bruh
okay and by the way she goes and with
peace and love to her
like don't say it she but no but like
she go out and she's
doing these beautiful at any size things
which is fine you could be
into that but she airbrushed everything
out and it's like
talk about unrealistic beauty stanzas if
you want to be beautiful at any size you
better not start photoshop
photoshopping all the [ __ ] like
cellulite out and [ __ ]
i'm my only fans i don't photoshop
anything i think you're awesome for that
okay but you are targeting you
sorry i have a drink in my mouth the
initial conversation was
that you are true representative of the
fat community
you can't but you signalling out it's
like awesome because okay
fat people already have it hard enough
so of course like when skinny people
have a problem like of course everyone
agrees on that but no one like calls
them out for it
you're calling fat people out because
you're fat phobic you why don't you in
that same token you can call no but
there's
don't you do you just do you disagree
that there's this movement of like
healthy at any time
okay so then maybe maybe the premise of
our argument do you think chris farley
was like i'm healthy and big like
no that's a new thing that movement
didn't exist when chris
am i crazy or is there a whole like
healthy at every size thing
can someone back me up on this get every
size
moses is giving me nods moses definitely
doesn't know don't i mean
you're not dan you better [ __ ] speak
up don't
i'll stop nobody is saying hey
i'm fast okay okay so then okay okay
good i agree
look at how healthy okay good so maybe
this is our fitness test okay
we're on the same page people even i was
like confused when you're like wow
treasure really impressed me blinking a
minute i'm like
big ass fat people can do that that's
not that hard it's not that difficult
see you're
not because you're like wow you can
playing for a minute oh my god you act
like i'm [ __ ] a whale like an orca
like jesus no well first of all i
thought you were out of shape
okay i'm a dancer i danced on tour
exactly so
so it wasn't a fat phobic i didn't
expect you could do it
you think i'm not fat why no that's
that's you being out of shape easy a
planking okay so what does it say you
say i'm not fat but i couldn't do it so
what does that mean that means you're
out of shape and that's what i thought
about you
and that's what i thought about you and
i thought you were out of shape
i'm fat but i'm in okay shape you're not
fat and in bad shape so that just proved
my point that doesn't matter how did
that prove your point
because you're saying not that i thought
you couldn't you're blank because you
are out of shape
because i'm fat and a little fake and
little children
you only thought i was out of shape
because i'm fat there was no other
indicator to tell you that
listen if the evidence if you take the
evidence that
is available to you okay i'm [ __ ]
sherlock holmes and i'm looking
up and down i'm saying that girl can't
do a plank cause i'm fat that's fat
phobic and that bad
just drawing a conclu drawing a
conclusion based on someone's weight
does not make them fat phobic
that literally is it we all make
assumptions every day about different
things because i'm
unhealthy because i'm fat yes i can but
i'm not like i can run
i can go that's my point girl you just
said you did the slowest smile
world record slow smile walking do the
last episode five miles at hermosa beach
like i can i can walk all day long i
have a good stamina that's why i'm so
excited to get a treadmill like i have
good stamina
i can have sex for two hours can you no
you don't even go on top that's what you
told me
look and i agree i'm fat and out of
shape
but you're a bet you're in better shape
than me you're not fat and you're more
unhealthy than me
i well apparently so
am i gonna get canceled am i did i say
something really
bad just tell me now oh it's break time
so
do me a favor let's do the ad cancel me
after the ad get a biscuit and put some
honey on it
for why for the honey ad oh that ain't
cute all
right okay cancel me after that
cancer me out i can't don't edit no i'm
not i just i don't know if people can be
mad at me
i don't know either i don't know yeah i
mean either i was like
it was just like a car crash and then
you don't know
you just you think you're alive but
we'll find out after the episode though
all right let's do the ads and then
we'll come back and talk about the real
juice david dobrik and james charles
don't be mad at me these guys actually
did something wrong i was just making
just making exceptions about that argue
fat phobia is the worst of all these
things
oh stop james charles is out there like
sexting six year olds and you're gonna
[ __ ]
cancel me first thinking you could have
plank
i'm not the only one that didn't think
your ass couldn't blanket by the way
started with and by the way
it started with you saying i can do a
push-up guarantee and your ass gonna
even move up like one millimeter
pull up and i didn't know what a pull-up
was if i knew the definition of that i
would have changed my
two whatever you thought it was
you were not even close neither were you
i was a lot closer cheated people
thought
i saw the cops well they're right you
did one
i mean pretty much exactly um let's do
that
thank you guys don't cancel me until
after this semester is commercial break
okay this episode is brought to you by
adam and eve um
wait what's the slash use the code h3
for 50 off and give you fifty percent
off any single item plus is it h3 or hd
podcast
it's there's no slash it's just the h3
code you enter the code h3 guys
listen up 50 off any single item plus
free shipping if you're in the us and
canada and guess what adam and eve comes
in discreet packaging that means no
return label if you live with someone
it'll be nice discreet package you don't
want your mom seeing that
well if you're college right now they
have
heated rabbits that means dildos that
heat up inside of you
it is inside yet blowing you push the
heat button
oh you activate the heat you activate
the exact heat activated dildos right
now that are absolutely
amazing they have ones that inflate
inside you i did a whole video on it but
does it sometimes get too toys wait
inflatable sex horses
no and sex toys inflate inside of you oh
amazing you guys go to wait what what is
it wait what
what extra with h3 code that you don't
even get with my mode and i have
questions
wait i have questions h3 code you i
will also get you free gifts for her
free gifts for you
six spicy movies dvds you get
free toys with the code h3 plus free
shipping plus 50 off
please use it get those inflatable sex
toys support the show
support this show we need your help
listen this is i'm going to have a lot
of litigation pending after this
i'm going to need your support did you
have any questions about this
what the [ __ ] is an inflatable sex toy
it's a rabbit that goes inside of you
and once it's inside of you
it expands so it fills you completely it
gives you like satisfaction that's a
good feeling
yeah oh that gives that kind of thing
gives men like dick uh
insecurity no it should be the opposite
because you know what well
um yeah true but like but the inflation
feels like when a guy's about to come
inside of you that's what it feels like
it's like this inflation inside of you
can i say that i don't know but anyways
but he's like no um it feels so so
freaking good okay what was the other
thing you said
um oh heated heated dildos so does it
ever get too hot you ever ever
come off the button or is it just subtle
no you can take it out
it's a nice one can you imagine the
scope
of sex toys that women have like you
guys have like an entire
no you guys have like an entire arsenal
of sex toys
you guys just did inflates that heats
look at this microphone that's just like
they have men what men get like a
[ __ ] like
a dispo i mean they have those on adam
and eve too you can get one of those um
flashlights flashlight flashlights are
everything you get flashlights you can
also get anal thrusters for you
you can get i think you're going to the
moon anal thrusters we just got a sea
ring a penis ring
oh god too much info it has ball
swinging on it quiet so it can hit you
at the same time and vibrate the clip
wait you have an extra pair of swinging
balls there are three little ones that
come off the
ring there's they're coming so it's like
he has four balls the ring this is the
three little metal balls and then
there's a vibrator up here so it's it's
you she's turned it bro you she i'm
sorry the balls are going like this
she turns your balls into a [ __ ] like
pendulum where it like knocks three
it's like an extra set above there so
it's like true and then poo and then poo
and then
that's what it's like sounds like
complicated if you want to get 50
off any of the toys we mentioned please
go to additional.com use the code h3
it'll give you 50
off plus all those free toys plus free
shipping if you're interested in canada
check it out adamne.com use code h3
what she said okay listen up
if you're using the internet without
honey it's basically
having intercourse with a girl you just
met
in a cd dive bar without a condom do you
understand this analogy i'm making
it's just not safe oh also you're just
losing money so it's just dumb so
safe and not safe safe and it's not safe
and it's dumb here let me tell you why
honey is basically the condom of the
internet when you shop online
you know there's codes all over the
internet
that could be saving you money now let's
say you go to uh
newegg that's just that's a website i
like to sell digital stuff
you know about new way yeah really yeah
no you don't i'm not a nerd like you
but you know about it you are no idea
what that is okay that's what i thought
but let's say you go to newegg to buy
some uh
ram you know what ram is right
you don't i'm not a nerd brand
okay let's say you go to
the let's just stick with the ram
analogy for brevity's sake
so we're at newegg we're buying ram okay
it's 500
put it in checkout you're gonna pay full
price you know there's a [ __ ] coupon
out there
honey automatically scans the internet
to find the best coupon
and automatically applies it boom so all
of a sudden you're at checkout buying
that ram from newegg
that 500 you don't know maybe he's going
to turn it to
300 that [ __ ] happens to me all the time
honey is literally save people listen to
this over two billion dollars in savings
i believe it for their 17 million
members i buy all my makeup online and
honestly like i never like you never get
discounts on makeup but with honey they
already
like give you the discount code so
you're saving money even though like
they're not discounting the makeup
they're scouring the ads for you so if
you buy it from sephora or like me i
bought mine on ulta
i got cash back i didn't even know and
it honestly really does work honestly i
was like
okay just giving me those fat checks
dude it works
it takes two clicks it's a browser
extension on chrome and other browsers
it's on other browsers right it's got to
be it check check the store it's on your
goddamn apps
honey two clicks about it being but the
thing is
it's not really a catch you just put it
on your browser saves money free
free boom boom boom put a condom on when
you [ __ ]
that's the and you never have to take it
off you put it on once and this is the
condom that lasts forever and never take
it off it'll always just be and it still
feels good it feels just as good it
feels great because you don't even know
what's coming
it's the best condom ever honey that's
the new slogan
joinhoney.com so here's the uh call to
action guys get ready for this if you
want to support the show
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally
free it stalls in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this podcast
get honey for free at dronehoney.com
frenemies that's jointhoney.com
frenemies that's our first like
frenemies code
i think we need to join really support
that
yeah we're getting a friend of me it's
just it's fun to say and spell
iconic icon moment that's
jumping the shark okay okay join honey
dot com slash frenemies
free do it now save money when in life
okay we are moving on
to david dobrik update so let me just
play this video
some of you guys probably already saw it
but i'm gonna play it for those of you
who haven't
this video was this is
the backstory and this is awesome
because it was posted to a highlights
channel
which is like a fan account of david's
and the timing was so weird because they
they dug up this clip of them talking
about the seth prank
back on the podcast it was like a total
expose but they were like posting it
on the fan channel i don't know if they
were just trying to get views on it or
what or
what do you why do you mean it was a fan
channel was the chat you know it's a fan
channel
okay well first of all this video
there's like a views clip channel but
it's not theirs
no it was a fan channel how do you know
it's a fan that could be a hater being
like exposing these people
i guess but at whatever it was just a
clip channel where they were just
like you know getting easier was it all
scandalous clips no no no that's what i
mean what was this titled
it was david speaks on seth kissing
jason prank
and this is new they just uploaded it
since they they just uploaded it like
two days ago
but it's the most compelling
illuminating
take on this whole thing and just so you
know
david's mcn did a strike did a mcm take
down on this video
like the day after we showed it in our
podcast here i'll show you
uh i have a screenshot
yeah the new york times in a story on
his new like app but not this i'm like
of course they're like oh disposable
whatever the [ __ ] it is and then it was
like
but he literally has all these like is
this like actual assault too i could go
to like
there could be like a i don't know i
hope there's something cause like like
you're saying the only way to get
through is like a lawsuit otherwise they
just keep going like there's gonna be
fans immediately after our podcast
this clip you can you see it dan this
video contains content from collab drm
who has blocked it on copyright's ground
now rem
now mind you there's like thousands of
clips on this channel
none of which are being removed yeah of
course it's just incriminating
so but like dude how about you just
acknowledge it instead of trying to
sweep all this up are you going to show
it
of course i'm going to show it well why
they are down it all fell off
hey i got lawyers and i got money and i
got nothing better to do oh my god i
love this
like david he's not going to take it i
love this attitude i love it when you're
this ethan where you're like
let's do it listen nobody [ __ ] gonna
silence me if there's one thing
i don't back down from a fight
especially one you're like a low-key
boss
like you are like i wish baby boss
i look like a boss baby here right now
no no but like i wish you would have
included the clips of us going into
rolls royce because you went in with
like
teddy fresh shorts and open can of soda
and you walked into this rolls royce
place and i was like
those kind of boss right now because
we're supposed to be like at ogar you
want to be like more like you know dress
nice to be like you know we're
respectful here but you're just like
don't give up no are we not supposed to
say that
no i don't care i'm just like who i
don't care about these people you
literally and you also didn't see the
car it was like
i'll take it i was like oh my god boss
okay
i'm glad i impressed you hey it was that
was really cool i was like wow okay
but when it comes to people like my last
lawsuit was all about this guy who was
trying to get me to shut up when i was
making fun of him i'm like this is not
the way
that this [ __ ] works and at the time i
was dead broke but i still wouldn't back
down
and i ain't [ __ ] back numb from david
that's for sure hell no
wow you're the one who couldn't now i
have money
so he ain't [ __ ] he ain't gonna
outspend me in the court no you're
i think you're more baller than another
matter no i don't think you are for sure
no david's rich i know about you i know
about your
david has that like um
no david's got that uh that qr code
money was that dumb [ __ ] puzzle yeah
david's got that crazy child lottery
money he probably made so
much money from that puzzle that's so
[ __ ] what if we
i bet you he made like 10 million
dollars plus from that puzzle yeah maybe
you're right
i think we should market these frenemies
little twinkies
god i don't want to sell food do you
know what a nightmare that is no but
um sam and ian can be making that and
delivering them
i have an idea we sell each one for a
hundred dollars but here's the
here's the thing there's a tiny little
piece of paper inside with a qr code
and if you scan it you might win a
hundred thousand dollars that's good
i also thought well no i saw this in the
comments you know it's so cringy too
sorry to interrupt you but like logan
paul
and casey neistat and all these super
rep reputable
youtubers not reputable but okay i like
casey he's a nice guy
let's do it let's do a court case on him
or what is it called contact
let's not but anyway remember when he
did the little cops was he a content cop
yeah he where'd he go he just
disappeared he's like bye no he didn't
do spirit he's doing his thing i love
ian god bless him oh his name is ian
yeah is that t
i never heard his name definitely not t
everybody knows his name
um so so um they were all they're all
like oh david dobrik such a genius he's
such a genius this thing he's
this is such a good idea i'm like guys
this is not a good idea it's just what
you think of when you have
literally like no when you are totally
uh unscrupulous and you don't care about
fleecing kids
like this this puzzle is basically the
analogy for
david's puzzle is somebody who
holding up a kid by his legs and
jiggling
money out of their pocket but that just
from my point he said because we all
know logan paul is gummy and has no
moral ground obviously with the code
that's stopping you
thought of it okay but then you were
saying no casey i like casey but if
casey is also co-signing a logan paul
and david dobrik saying this isn't
genius i mean just bad
it shows you no mentality he made him he
made it misogynistic if he's female he
cannot talk to you he will look the
other way and just talk to david jason
and anyone else in the room with the
female
right i was thinking okay okay let me
ask you this films
i was gonna ask casey neistat and the
vlog squad at the steamy
okay wait wait wait wait wait wait who
do you hate more jacks phil jackson's
okay
just making sure no but i think he would
jump
at a table you already worked do you
have a whole enemy list of people who
just didn't look at you
that table specifically i don't remember
okay
yeah that [ __ ] went down you opened a
grudge man the shorty awards in new york
city
2018 or 2019 or whatever year 2018 it
was
everything it was awful but anyways
casey neistat is misogynistic i'm just
saying that because he didn't look at
you
no because i would talk to him and he
literally ignored literally ignored he
was just like so
maybe he didn't hear you six different
times i can count six different times
david's christmas party where we have
the giant wrapping presents i can count
the shorty awards i can count so many
times for tonight conversation with him
and he literally would not acknowledge
me if jason was like this is my
girlfriend trish never acknowledged me
never was like hi
no i swear on my life
oh okay what happened wait what happened
what did you just remember i can't you
better tell it right now girl i'm gonna
flip this [ __ ] table
i'm gonna smash this set i'm gonna tear
these curtains down
information and you don't want it i
didn't get it i'm respecting it but oh
yeah
don't go there i was so pissed when you
did it i was like are you kidding me
i think you said it to me
what about the mystery text because i
mentioned it on the last show
i was like i got these crazy texts no no
no no no no no no no no
i got these crazy about me i know can i
say what the text said without saying
his name
hold on let me just preface this i said
i got these crazy texts from somebody
so unexpected like i have never received
texts like this before it was like
[ __ ] you you're a douchebag now you
really can't say who else can i
but then can i just say my part of it
and i won't say this everybody voted
unanimously
do not say the name that's [ __ ] if
someone came at me like that
are you kidding me that's what i thought
are you kidding me like
that's worse you're saying it privately
like okay if you say it out loud you
want like beef clout whatever but you're
saying this to me privately are you kid
are you [ __ ] kidding me i feel like
it was so unwarranted i just i don't
know why
it was so what and the stuff about me in
it i was just like
oh like who are you that was uncalled
for trying to say my little part
okay okay no there he said or this
person said
he was like oh sorry i don't watch your
show aka
the trisha paytas image rehabilitation
show i'm like okay
bitter like i'm sorry the whole
internet's not just [ __ ] on me all
the time like he was so bitter
first of all obviously you watch it if
you know my image has been rehabilitated
thank you very much
but second of all i was just like what
why is he so aggressive about he was so
aggressive about it i mean aggressive
towards you the other side oh my god he
was so
and he would apparently he was mad okay
i don't give about too much information
then you guys will figure it out
i saw people trying to guess though
don't try to guess because then that
just that just
i don't want to no because i don't want
because there's a lot of wrong
guesses do you know what i mean and i
don't like that there was one
one day i'm going to spill it i'm going
to be like a time bomb i'm going to
[ __ ] spill this tea one day because i
get it it's just in me
and it's been in me ever since you sent
me those text messages uh
one day i'm just gonna actually well i
wish i shouldn't have said that maybe
i'll say it one day don't
you get a clickbait your own [ __ ] now
you give away my tea it's not even your
tea to spill
i did it on the second channel the one
you don't know how to find so you'll
never see it
do a [ __ ] all crazy ass thumbnail but
like
but he was mad because you called him
fat apparently remember he said that
i know you don't kind of say i apologize
that no i was you know what i get it
it does no you just gave it away can i
apologize for saying he's fat
i feel like it's funny just to leave
that one clue that's
it that's one clue
can i apologize that on that on that
note can i just apologize to him because
i feel like i shouldn't
to the person we're not aiming yeah okay
okay no because i think this is sincere
no no no i'm not saying it i'm not
saying it i'm not saying it
i am not saying it dan okay okay but
seriously
don't cut this out because i want to say
like i do like that obviously
like you know how we call each other fat
it's fine like when you call each other
fat and your friends and you're cool
like that's our thing
but i think like i start thinking that
way like oh you can just call people fab
because it doesn't mean anything to me
truly it doesn't mean anything to me fat
is fat whatever
so i do apologize like love is love it
clearly it clearly triggered him
and you know what i haven't seen you in
years you're probably not as fat as i
remember
that's that bad or no
well i don't know that it's necessarily
good i'm sorry i hurt your feelings and
triggered you like i don't want to
trigger anyone
right i haven't seen him in years
[Music]
i'm probably fatter than you just i'm
probably fatter than him and he's taller
than me i'm sure
okay sorry i think that squashes it i
think i'm
i'm listening i'm hearing ila's voice
right now
yelling at me for a while did i do this
but i didn't i didn't do anything i
didn't
ask for this he he texted me out of the
blue
and he sent me twitter dms at the same
time because i didn't
i didn't answer his twitter dm right
away so he texted my personal [ __ ]
phone number by the way
oh did you hear something yeah okay
oh my god the fatties are coming for me
they told me to cancel me i told you
they're stomping around upstairs like
t-rex that happened with susan summer
she was she was doing a show when
someone came into her house in a gated
community did you see that
no she was doing a live and some guy
just came into her house she goes who
are you
here you shouldn't be here uh yeah moses
you've got to
get moses yeah he's on it yeah he's he's
not that's why he's here he's a security
are you armed
he can't um okay what are you saying
okay
no no no no no now i'm in his breath he
messaged
and then he texted me i haven't talked
to this guy in years okay years
and then he texts off like [ __ ] you
douchebag how dare you this and that he
told me have a good life
yeah that was that was really weird i
was like i've been having a good life i
haven't talked to you in years i just
had to like bumble hookups that like
don't want to talk to me anymore they
like [ __ ] me never talk to me again i'm
like how are they live
like that's what i say to them anyway
but like i'm not gonna show the text but
this was like paragraphs and paragraphs
and paragraphs
and like i was like dude and my response
initially was like are you okay
like this seems odd i feel like we
barely like i've definitely been like
don't like this guy but like
casually like i say with everybody like
i don't like you like whatever you know
what i mean but this it was weird it was
odd it was it was strange and also like
i feel like we didn't really mention too
much of him other than like
whatever now every okay that's all i'll
say with peace
but apparently okay we gotta go back to
david are we gonna get to bryce out the
end or can i just say something real
quick
so what did bryce come on the show and
then you guys never responded all right
oh i didn't see that
bryce hall wants to come on the show oh
you think he wants to fight me
because last time i challenged him to a
fight he was trying to get in the same
room as me
in the dm's did you read the screen he's
definitely gonna try to fight me if we
bring him up no he said i don't hate you
guys i just want to explain what was
wrong he's a little [ __ ] he's gonna
come and bring a cat back i love that
though him trolling the media
you're gonna bring a cat bag and be like
um here's a put you're a [ __ ] here's
your
cat okay i gotta go hey i saved the
receipt i gotta go return that at
ralph's he did ask for your address so
no he did it no i don't believe that but
did he ask for my address
he said what's the addie i started too i
said she's screaming recordings it's not
like i guess i don't know if that's okay
i guess it's fine
you didn't send him my address no i
stopped responding because i didn't know
if you really because i was you didn't
send him my address
yeah i did then i put your name at the
gate i was like you know what right now
is coming shut up what is tick-tock
collab though maybe he did that for
though like he's like wow
these old people probably want clout
watch me dm them and then say yes no he
definitely
he definitely thinks he's like doing a
troll a galaxy brain where he's going to
show up and try to fight me remember
when he
that's kind of everything i mean if i if
i have
so like if we go okay come and i have
like some huge samoan dude who will like
body slam him
like standing behind the curtain and he
doesn't know he's there and he tries to
get tough with me
this huge simone will come and [ __ ]
face plant yeah
good idea dan if bryce hall like punched
you
that's a clip yeah yeah
it's a good clip but especially if i
have a secret samoan
who's going to come body flash take the
punch that's funny this is not funny
i'll
i don't want to take a punch i would
take a punch for a clip i'm not going to
get
out played by bryce hall if he's gonna
come here and try to give me the l i'm
gonna have ten
[ __ ] samoans i think you give him too
much credit i really do
listen i'm not a fighter i'm i can't
beat up anybody i'm a fighter let alone
a little roided ass [ __ ] little
eight-year-old 18 year old
i'm a bryce house i i'm coming around to
bryce hall he reached out he made an
effort to clear his dude he's galaxy
braining he wants to come fight me
for sure first i had to look up his age
james charles i had to look at his age
before i even responded i was like let
me just make sure this guy's like 18
because moses said that he's like how
old is he i'm like you know let's look
this up how old is he 21.
he's 21 yeah at 21 is like legal enough
you know
so dan should i invite him on him if i
have like 12 simones hidden behind the
curtain
yeah you guys are not about it hey look
even it comes to trellis iconic love
that i want to see his trolling cause
remember when he's like joining the
media with that girl that no one knew no
but his trolling isn't funny he just
watched the fight i love watching people
but it's not it's not funny when he when
he comes over and it's like honey
it's not because he doesn't allow calm
he's just like
he just wants to fight but that's funny
okay bryce you're invited over bryce's
all just trying to hit you i'm gonna
have 12 samoans planted
all over this house they're going to
[ __ ] tear you apart like
please don't come up what was it called
back in the day when they were like
tearing them apart by limbs quartering
or something yeah
yeah i'm gonna have i'm gonna have 12
big ass simone's drawing quarter here as
well you only need four for that
so
oh my god i love that we're gonna need
12 samoa all right yeah
yeah jason momoa he's the mom you think
he'll come on the show
uh yeah yeah all right so let's watch
this video we just we can't even
think david will come on the show david
i think
there was maybe a time where who would
but that [ __ ] was definitely sales okay
i'm still like bitter
that like i still want to be in their
front group and that's why nobody thinks
that nobody
i nobody should think that let's watch i
just want to watch this club because
we're not getting anywhere there's been
an hour we haven't even talked about
really on the show said that but okay
no i'm saying i don't i don't think
i hope and pray to god that people don't
think that because it's so ridiculous
okay let's watch this here oh let's talk
about this
everything's happy but today we pulled
the prank it proves everything even
worse than i thought and by the way i
can't get over how jason goes wit
listen to jason let's talk about this
what really made me happy
what to do
i feel bad for jason he's such a little
background he's like a eunuch you know
what that is
like from game of thrones where they
chop their dick off totally him
yeah that's the vibe he's like so
neutered david nick
yeah eunice total eunuch they chop the
dick and the balls off so they can't
have kids and so they can't be committed
to their work that's literally him with
david like david has his dick
there you go cool shout out oh let let's
talk about this what really made me
happy
today we pulled a prank on oh
on my friend seth oh it's great yeah
yeah and now you can talk about it
it's probably the best prank i've ever
i've ever pulled on anyone in my opinion
it was we have this scary mask that
we've been pranking people with and it's
just a scary mask and everyone knows
that that it's it's a mask
and i told him i told seth hey man i
want to do this bit
it's like a dream sequence where you
where you make out
with the masked guy and it just looks
like you're dreaming and you're making
out with an old man because
the mask makes you look like an old man
and i'm like karina's going to be in it
and karen is a girl
in my vlogs and he's like and he's he
thinks karen is really attractive so
kind of like the hot girl in david's
vlogs yeah so so he's like
so he's like yeah i'm totally down and
i'm like yeah seth just don't hold back
you can make out as much as you want
have as much tongue as you want just
keep so that to me is first disturbing
thing is that he
encouraging seth to make out and go for
it
and use tong as much right right
right you couldn't just do like a kiss
prank yeah no he's like go for it it's
karina
you like her so that's number one creepy
vibe
and but what what seth didn't know is
that i replaced corinna with jason
so jason was under the mask and that's
such a [ __ ] creep how he's like
like dude how are you okay and like
laughing and
he's like it's like dude how old do you
have anything
i know so gross oh no like it makes me
physically sick i think i like just
because like
they did so much like so much of this
stuff like right or like seth is like
one person forget about it but they did
so much there's a kid in the vlog's name
jonah he'll never speak out on him
because he's still friends and like up
their ass or whatever he's like
he's on their videos still though yeah
he's the best go ahead go ahead say it
i don't mean that to make it away yeah
he's fat
but like he's in love they put him in
peace and up they put him in so many
like
really bad positions like dangerous
missions they would have him like flash
people and like he wouldn't want to like
he flashed me like i did not want to see
his penis like his penis what would they
make
they did he'd be like jonah pull your
pants down and people would just like
laugh like
like he did it and like jonah would be
like weird oh my god he's why is he
that's like sexual i didn't want to see
it i got flash i never asked for it i
was like and then there was like a bit
where like
uh it's joe was like sunbathing it was
like david or someone else and they were
like naked and like i'm like they were
constantly like flashing people but
jonah did a lot
and i was just like how is that okay
like exposing yourself like it's so
crazy so anyways
the point is like watching this makes me
physically sick because they thought it
was so funny and the
the worst part about this is even when i
came out with my [ __ ] about like brandon
dating a 17 year old
they wanted me to apologize like if you
just apologize to david and brandon like
everything will be okay and i was like
apologize for what like it was it was
always that mentality dude i
literally it's so sick these two guys
after listening to this
it gives it goes on it gets worse and
worse everyone everyone in the room's
like this isn't going to work everyone
doubted you yeah yeah everyone brandon
corinna like this isn't going to work
this is stupid because of the size
difference because the size about six
feet
another important thing was that people
were saying
this he was in on it there was no way it
could be real because of the size
difference like for
people were saying they thought seth was
in on it
because and because of the size
difference so and they that's what
people who are accusing seth
of lying yeah but he walks in but i'm
just saying that the fact that they
acknowledge that here
proves once again what we all know is
that
this is this was that seth
was not in on this right yeah i mean
yeah that's
clear and then the bit starts going and
seth is there sitting on the couch
jason walks in as karina he's not
speaking obviously
sits next to her seth leans in and as
he's leaning in i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i got it it's game over it's
in the bag
i sit down i put my hand i put my hand
on seth's knee
and i put my hand behind his back and
start rubbing his back and squeezing his
knee
wait what and then he just just
leans in and just goes at it i slip him
the tongue first
this is also a common thing that jason
keeps saying with all these jokes with
tana it was a joke with tana like i
leaned in for the kiss and it was like a
joke for the vloggers there was no
cameras recording like it's constantly
just saying like oh i put my hand on his
back and that's like not part of the gag
that's not okay so jason says he put his
hand on his knee
on his back and he slipped him the
tongue first do you know how disturbing
that is
so once again they put seth in the
situation they tricked him
and jason made the first move by putting
his tongue
into his mouth you know seth said
something interesting in the interview
with him
he thinks that and it made it even kind
of worse for him in a way is that
he thinks jason was getting sexual
gratification from this
i don't doubt it which is like seth is
right that makes
it more disturbing i mean it's already
disturbing if it happened
like and it happened twice not that it
needed to happen but if he said like i
put my hand on his d
it back like anyone who's doing like a
kissing prank i don't even know it's
like a thing but like if you
when you're doing that like it's not
like you do everything else with it like
that's not part of it that wasn't the
thing david said up like okay we're
gonna have you caressing
like it's cresting his leg his thigh
that does sound like taking advantage of
being in a prank like that was the thing
like oh it's for the vlog so
it's okay like right that's their
justification for literally anything
yeah like i was saying with the tana
thing too when he like kissed her for
the vlog even though there's no cameras
he's like he he uses the excuse like oh
it's for the vlog when in reality he
just wanted to
like be a perfect here see here here's
where it really works i say oh it's for
the podcast i bleached my hair
right for the podcast i shave off my
eyebrows for the podcast
sexually it's back it up backward i
can't say that
essay right dan thank you youtube i
can't say
i have to say essay that's not something
you can do for
a gag is my point yeah this is a gag
right assaulting someone not a gag
yeah i think that's probably thank you
something everyone agrees on yeah thank
you
i mean you would think that there would
be something in your brain especially
jason
being like nearly 50 years old with kids
where you'd be like okay
i have a mask on i'm slipping my tongue
down the student's throat i'm touching
him in sexually suggestive ways
they would think like with no consent of
course no consent would they would think
like
this there's something about this that i
should not be doing he doesn't think
that at all like even
when our situation happened he literally
still was just like brandon did nothing
wrong with dana miner you're being crazy
like
this is there's nothing wrong with any
of this like he kept saying that to me
like i was the water and i was just like
like he doesn't think he did anything
wrong he had another incident with like
an 18 year old like after we had broken
up and like she had dm
or whatever and he's just like there's
nothing wrong with it she's 18 she's not
it's like
like there was a situation and i'm not
gonna say because it's not my story as
hell but it was just like he doesn't get
it like it just he doesn't get it who do
you think's more to blame in the
situation david or
jason or equally i think it's equal
blame obviously he's doing this stuff
for david and stuff but
i do think jason is getting something
out of it in all honesty i really do i
know he
like i know because no one else would do
this unless you've got some sort of
gratification especially going that far
it's one thing for david to be he took
it way too far yeah
and the way he talks about it he wasn't
like ew he was like
yeah he's like it was great it was one
like it was i slipped the tongue like
why are you saying those details like
that like it's also just like
why would you oh i just but in a way it
is like the cult of david so how i see
it is like david is obviously adolf
hitler
right and jason is just following orders
kinds of vibe you know what i mean right
right
sorry i thought you're gonna be like
he's like the ava
is like i don't think ava commit i don't
think
i don't know much about ava
just like sucking a dick is what i meant
like sucking david's day oh but he's
actually doing
crimes he's like he's like in the
concentration camps you know what i mean
which one oh one of the good ones one of
the really prolific ones
jason jason's a nazi concentration camp
killer is this a schindler's list
reference i'm just making an analogy
because a lot of the okay so
world war ii trivia a lot of the guards
who committed mass genocide said we were
just following orders right
so that's like a famous kind of pro
proverb of i was just following
right so so david is adolf hitler
right because when we and jason is let's
say well goebbels is he's hard to
yeah he's just he's a he's a
concentration camp uh
killer he's a he's a mass murderer jason
and he was just following orders he's
like
you with me and gloria yes exactly yeah
thank you so okay okay great
like with tongue they start making out
and at this point
we're like five seconds in and i'm like
this is it this is what i wanted i got
what i wanted i'm out like we can end
this
and i'm like seth seth like i'm ready to
talk he's coming now he's coming into my
mouth with his tongue so
hard you could tell his tongue is did he
grab my ass
he grabbed your ass he grabs jason's ass
cause he thinks it's corinna
at this point the poor dude probably has
a boner
and he's really making out with jason
and i'm like seth
seth seth and i'm trying to get him to
stop but he thinks it's part of the bit
and he keeps going for 25 seconds
literally i'm not over exaggerating it's
in the vlog 25 seconds making out with
this guy
and i'm like i i literally i think i
looked up to the ceiling and i'm like
god what did i do to deserve such a
beauty and i'm oh yeah wait what because
what does that mean he was like oh this
is such a good moment for my video
he wasn't thinking about like you know
seth he was just like
score great moment for my video it's
like dude if you were worried about
going that long you could have stopped
it at any minute and jason by the way
you sick [ __ ] you could have pulled away
too
yeah why didn't he if the gag was done
exactly
please stop and then meanwhile he's like
got his tongue down his throat
he's sitting there going david call it
please yeah i'm sure you're dead
wasn't there the situation with greg
paul like kissing girls
and they thought yeah it's the same so
everyone i'm gonna give credit to
creepshow art for
doing a video she called him the jake
paul light and nobody was really giving
david [ __ ] because there was so much
like hoopla around jake paul and logan
ends up being like the scandalous ones
but this is the exact same thing it
actually like
it's worse it's worth it yeah you're
right it's actually worse and it's just
like
how i mean the great one was pretty
creepy but but this
is worse i mean could be i mean i feel
like the severity of it and like the
amount and they knew his background and
how this would damage him and where he
came from and like
which they get which they get into which
i think is the most important part about
this video which we'll cover
it's going on and on and it is so
aggressive like they're making out like
super aggressive
and then i call karen into the room and
karen is standing right next to me
by the way notice how he acknowledges
that he could end it any time
and he did when he called karina into
the room right so it was up to david
when it
ended and he ended it after you know 30
seconds
enough to thoroughly humiliate seth like
seth
seth and then seth finally lets up after
25 seconds of making out jason
and he sees karina and he just [ __ ]
loses it
yeah it was great it was my favorite
it was so perfect and i feel so bad and
it's just it's
it's awful because poor guy had to go
through that
and his friends are probably gonna chew
him out for that for the next like
three five years of his life boom done
closed case
he knew exactly what he was doing wait
it gets even worse it gets even worse
so he said this is uh yes i've seen it
did you have you talked to him yeah i
talked to him i was like
i was just setting my condolences and i
just i feel like
because people have called him a liar
and called him a cloud chaser and all
these terrible things for trying to talk
about this for so long
that i just
he hadn't no he didn't know about this
clip before it started circulating
but like just so you know i want you to
see this so that you know
that everything you felt was right right
right right and that it proves
everything he said that's so crazy and
even when he was like when he said there
was a racial component it was like
you're like it could it's like it could
be it could be
but like it's hard to know like is there
a racial component to this
but like they say it and so yeah
i even you know listen to this part
well as seth tells it the homosexuality
is not so accepted in his where he comes
from
that's from compton dude's kissing dudes
is not so excited that's from compton so
it's like the perfect
like these straight dudes kissing
literally the perfect setup like
a guy from compton and i made a makeout
with another older man
it's good
he was angry as he could be the way you
speak about david's vlog is
like you guys admitted to heaven like i
was like you made it like
what air time it's so weird i didn't
hear that part that's
so gross to me these people are so oh
yeah they justify it by saying
he got good air time he got humiliated
but then seth also tells them that he's
like uncomfortable like yeah he was like
he was mad about it or whatever like
that it's like if he tells you
uncomfortable he doesn't want in the
blog like
and he's still listening listen to what
david says right here listen
it gets him it gets him some air time
seth was really
gets uh initiated into the vlog he was
as angry as he could have been but he
really couldn't
he was like angry as he could have been
i'm so [ __ ] well and then the fact
that they go they it proves it was
racially motivated because when seth was
telling the story
i was like why did they call you because
he's like i just got back from the
airport i was going home i was tired
he wasn't with them and then david
specifically calls me and tells me to
come over
so i was like why are they targeting you
specifically and then he says here
it was a perfect setup because he's from
compton where homosexuality
isn't accepted and we knew that it would
be especially bad for him
a black man from compton because kissing
dudes as jason said isn't accepted there
it's [ __ ] so like just like hate
crimes for him and stuff like that like
if he like goes back or people see it or
whatever like that like it's so
dangerous yeah and then seth had to move
to a new state he literally moved out of
state
that's and they did it to him again
twice with gorillas
and now we know that there's racial
motivation and then he set him up the
second time with a bunch of gorillas
and like it's being it's so [ __ ] up
dude it's so fun
it's so [ __ ] up it's unforgivable
david needs to answer this this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] up like
apologize for it first of all like that
could be the first step the fact that
he's
blocking taking down like just carrying
on life like completely normal
it's like insane it's insane first of
all oh seth an apology for letting
everybody call him a clout chasing
goblin and a liar and all this ball
and maybe let your like dumbass audience
know like hey this is not cool because
they're still attacking son
now saying then they put on me like oh
you know trisha that has nothing to do
with me but
these people are so warped and like
their brain so like david needs to
address and be like this is wrong like
this is [ __ ] up so they're his fans
you're right it's crazy that's all he
has to say but then like the racial
component once he admits to that
it's it's like oh and then here's the
best part
you know what this video i was gonna
leave this and let it go
but when this video surfaced for me it
made everything
so much worse and then if it does to
make things even better
david's going on a no bullying tour
literally a [ __ ] no
bullying tour oh my god it's [ __ ]
nuts he's
he's on the poster of a no hate tour so
it's like one thing to like not taking
apart really apologize but now you're
gonna be like hey here's how not to
bully
what someone gets so angry at you and so
wait did they
i don't know if they were moved to oh
you know he's here he's still here
all cute with his tongue out put your
tongue in your [ __ ] mouth okay well i
think that's the least of our problems
well well okay that's a good point true
david dobrik is still on the no hate
tour who literally made
is made famous by being a [ __ ] bully
and uh
and assaults people on camera thanks no
hate hey guys
not respecting any consent if someone's
like i don't want that in the vlog and
put it in like anyways like just
absolutely
and no boundaries no consent nothing
like that's
i tweeted out i thought it was pretty
good you told me you rate this tweet
i said sending david dobrik on a bowling
prevention tour is like sending me
around the world to teach people how to
lose weight
i mean honestly it makes more sense
because you are losing weight so
he has not stopping the hate enough he's
not allowing people to keep
spreading the hate but i don't know that
i'm necessarily the person to
teach anyone you're more capable because
you're trying to lose weight he's not
even trying he's not behaving okay let
me rethink this analogy encourage the
hate
let me rethink this analogy sending
david dobrik on an anti-bullying tour
is like um is like sending adolf hitler
out
to preach uh religious tolerance
hitler's dead right okay so he can't go
on a tour
good point that's it i'll keep thinking
okay
i've never heard that last part oh oh no
wonder their fans are still like
trisha's bitter and also like that
because they themselves are saying
it's good because you got air time for
the vlog oh what kind of rationale is
that oh it's the most
cynical it's the most cynical [ __ ] up
rationale ever it proves that david sees
people as
pawns in his [ __ ] like there's a
hierarchy and there's pawns
and like no and depending on how game
you are and how willing to debase you
are
that's how you move up like jason is the
most
he has no pride he has no he has no
filter he's willing to debase himself in
the most
sinister [ __ ] up demeaning ways
possible and so he's his golden boy of
course yeah of course
of course that's so insane
oh my god that's so crazy okay so
confused so then there's a whole nother
thing is that
i was looking at his new episode of
views because i saw like on some of his
tick tocks people were like yo you need
to address the says thing
and then i'll go back and all of them
were gone and then i went to his podcast
and there was no comments about seth and
i and it will just make me feel bad
because it's like
i'm trying to i'm doing so hard to do
awareness and and get some justice yeah
but so we did some tests on
his video because i suspected he was
blocking
words yeah and so oh my god here we have
a
we have a um did he block seth's name
he didn't block seth's name because i
think that would be too obvious but what
he did block
i have a list here okay so we went to
so here's here's how we conducted this
test because youtube has its own
filtering out of words and we want to
make sure that it was david and not
youtube
so we left a word on his and if it
didn't go through we went to our own
channel
and then saw sophie went through so for
example kiss and kissing are blocked out
of his
uh straight up blocked from his chat
so he's being sneaky about it oh right
because if you want you can say seth but
kiss and kissing is blocked
is he deleting the comments or no it's
automatic
is being removed but by the way so you
go maybe that's youtube we went to our
own channel and wrote that and
it did go through oh really so he is
blocking
and then there was more we did a bunch
of tests
but um
yeah you can see when you go to the
issue podcast and type
does not get removed oh my gosh it's
pretty crazy
wow so he's just like deleting things
deleting tick tocks and
yeah filtering out comments and stuff
wow
um just like wow wait hold on i saw this
really
um this guy has the best tick tock ever
oh my god did you just cough on a
cheeseburger jonah you fat [ __ ]
you so
people oh my god he's just always called
people like fast
no hey bro so what is that what's that
considered
um there's more by the way more clips
servicing from his podcast which is
a treasure trove now
so here they are this one's personal to
you trisha me
yes talking about when
again it it it prov it's crazy you know
yesterday i feel like people think
you're exaggerating when you talk about
how you were having sex with jason and
and
and david was in the bathroom oh right
yeah here they describe the entire
situation in full detail
yes i felt so bad for today an old clip
from the podcast
you ready for this i don't know we
showed up yesterday to vernon hills and
i i felt so bad for david because we
were with him for like a minute and we
just immediately started fighting about
something oh
yeah oh i should say this we were i was
i told jason that i was going to scare
trisha in her hotel room
when they got there so he called in the
front desk and he goes hey give david
over an extra key when he comes
and i got there and they gave me the key
and i'm hiding in the hotel room i hide
in the bathroom
like in the shower i'm waiting for them
and they [ __ ] start having sex
like as if jason did you forget no i
just got so turned on i just
that was weird and i and i was like oh
my god he's i i thought you were gonna
have sex like the entire time and just
finished
right just to like just to have that be
like the joke and i was like please
don't do it please don't do it
and then and then she ended up coming to
the bathroom fully naked
okay so they just ah people are so
dramatic saying oh she's in on it
whatever she was close they literally
just said
on their [ __ ] podcast which by the
way
okay what this really paints jason as a
complete
[ __ ] sexual deviant like david's like
why did you do this when i was in the
bathroom right he's like oh i was just
i didn't forget you were there i was
just turned on like i'm sorry what
and he specifically said can you go get
me a clinic in the bathroom that's how
he went into the bathroom he's like okay
so like he like knew to like
put me in there like completely naked he
could have been like oh he put a like
on or something right it was
what is wrong with these people dude how
do you
and then yeah yeah it's just because
you're telling these stories it sounds
so
fantastic but then they're they're
admitting to the whole [ __ ] thing on
their podcast
crazy that's insane that's so nuts and i
just but the thing is like
like literally they just keep ignoring
it and just goes away like it's insane
like i'm so glad we keep talking about
it because it's just like so insane to
not even say oh
sorry i apologize here's you crying
after it happened
i don't know if you remember this yeah
everything okay
yeah what was that on uh everybody's
just taking up all this [ __ ]
is everything
after that incident like you will not
find me in a vlog january 2019 because i
would that would happen december 2018.
you want me to find me in a vlog january
2019 because i i said i was like
that's the first time ever that i said i
was like besides the tana stuff uh it
was the first time i said like i don't
want that in the vlog i'm uncomfortable
with it i was like crying jason went
back to boston i supposed to go with him
and i went back i stayed in illinois
because i was like i'm not going back
like that's [ __ ] crazy i was so
pissed and like i wasn't in david's vlog
forever when jokes about it on the
podcast
you know it's crazy okay so here's how
little
anything matters anymore so we were
complaining that nobody covered it okay
so
buzzfeed unilad insider pop cult i don't
know who
sports keita sorry i'm celeb secrets
what the [ __ ] are these websites
buzzfeed's big yeah but no some of these
are really big distract the five film
daily yada yada philip defranco covered
it
and um and and he still
despite that and us talking about it
he's had been faced with so little
accountability that he's still
on the no hate no bowling tour like not
even the no bowling tour
is willing to say we are not comfortable
having someone committing
on camera twice that's crazy
that's crazy yeah wow i'm so good that's
so confusing on so many levels
you know oh my god there's a um they'll
just continue to get away with it which
is crazy
it's crazy when the when even the no
hate tours were unwilling to step in
then
i mean all hope is lost they're like yes
he has made a career out of bowling but
i i what is the deal with this no hate
war what are they are they making money
like
like what like what the what is
happening i don't know
i also feel like i'm going on a hate
tour no
we don't want to spread hate no no no no
no i'm starting a tour
we're going global the hate tour who are
we hating on
david don't break no hate i'm a [ __ ] i
am a world class hater
i'm not a hater oh yes you are i think
he needs to get rid of jason on the
podcast right of him completely because
that's a liability because he is a
sexual deviant
that's inappropriate david enables
everything he does i think just
jason well he will i tell you what he'll
he'll cut him off real quick like
jason's a dead weight i'm sorry but dave
david enables all this behavior
i totally agree he's the cult leader
like nick big nick said
oh for sure for sure jason is jason does
everything just to make daddy david
happy
i totally believe that too it's just
there is some weird thing there that he
keeps him along because he adds
absolutely no value to the podcast
that's the only thing we have going for
them right now i was like oh there's
something
between them there's something like
weird that he's holding on to jason
because jason everyone says like jason's
like doing nothing on this podcast he
literally says oh and the new one yeah
it's sad
it's sad what he did before jason i mean
that's literally what was that what are
you calling
you know that's literally the definition
of a unit sitting there with no he
needs to be on the couch they have a
move aside a tiny little chair
you know what they should do they should
just get him a dog house that he can
like
lay in yeah with a collar just get rid
of the chair [ __ ] it just give him a
little dog house with the opening you
could just see his head
like at the doghouse unleashed he has
leash and
okay we're going to talk about james
charles now and for this story
because i feel like it's so it's serious
enough it warrants me wearing this hat
are you doing that to like hydra we're
having a yeehaw moment you look dope
you really like this yeah it's cool you
should go out somewhere in your rolls
royce
i look like such a blow like such a
wannabe
like kid rock or some [ __ ] you look like
a jewish rapper like you and little
dicky could have an album together
you look dope i'm just looking at myself
in the you look cool
you look cool don't say that can you
sing a boy band do you know any in sync
um
or wait wait wait how's it going what's
the nc song which one which one
anyone any one i um
come on treasure you got nothing i never
wanted
that's right
[Music]
that was good we should do i do have
crazy boy band vibes
because a lot of these are just
timberlake of course that's the vibe
you're going for today
a lot of the guys in boy bands are like
not that handsome but they try really
hard they like do everything possible
like you're more of a joey than a
justice exactly yeah joey it's like
you're not that you're not really hot
but he tries his best
cute book in comparison to the others
like he's like he doesn't really fit
and joey's last name was fatone and it's
spelled fat one f-18
is it really yeah you know he's a really
successful like producer now
oh is he he like produces impractical
jokers he's like really
yeah should we get him on the show for
sure i love jeffy this is such a fat one
poor thing was always like oh is that a
mug shot what is that
i don't think that's a mug shot trisha
dude's
jesus you're like a mix
yeah you're like a joey photo i love
being fat one
i'm ethan what a horrible last name yeah
yo that's gonna be my rap name fat one
oh that sounds like a choke or something
i found one i got a fat one
yeah all right we're talking about james
strong thank you girl you look good
oh thank you for a friend of me we
should do like a sing-off competition
like
who's the better like performer i love
that idea
really
well hold on that doesn't mean anything
i mean hello
i've heard you sing it's not i'm better
than you
well let's prove it okay i mean you
could should we get like a casting
director like a broadway casting
director or something like hear our
voices
who's the better talent the dancing yeah
i mean we should have a
a panel for sure but uh
he might do it his fault i absolutely
think we should have a singing
competition
i get really nervous when i like okay
but yeah all right so james charles
anyway i got my hat on let's be serious
for a minute
james charles for like the 1 billionth
time is being exposed
for messaging underage boys
on snap let's see
he was outed by this one kid who's 16.
here let's just watch his video now how
many times does this happen i mean
people keep giving james charles the
slide this has gone
way too [ __ ] far the fact that he
like he admitted to this friday and this
morning was just like good morning
everyone
yeah as if like you didn't just like
literally commit a crime you literally
can't send nudes to minors like
like that's crazy that's and this is not
the first time
this means when there's a repeated
pattern of behavior it's no longer like
like i said this in my video i'll say it
again like this and i know this from a
therapist point of view right
like if it happens once you get called
out you know you learn from your
mistakes you [ __ ] up you're like [ __ ]
dude but if it's a repeated pattern yeah
this individual is an actual sick person
and that's fine but they either need
help
restriction or like a label to not be on
tick-tock to not be on these things
where there's children because clearly
he has predatory behaviors where he
self-admittedly on the logan paul said
that he likes young looking boys like he
likes you i have all that here
okay but i i totally agree it's like he
has gotten in trouble with this
narrowly escaped being canceled and he
still can't help himself from doing from
sending
inappropriate soliciting sending nudes
to to children
and so he's a predator it's insane and
how he sells a tick tock same way with
the lopez brothers like how do they
take talk he's a [ __ ] predator being
shown that through that app
through snapchat or whatever through
tick tock they've like met these young
kids this guy is like after this let's
watch the video but he's a predator like
there's no there's no debating it
there's no debate he's just straight up
a predator here
so trigger warning i will be talking
about grooming and james charles so if
you get triggered by
any of those keep scrolling but if not
watch this i love the insinuation of
just james charles alone is triggering
i mean he is are you kidding me he's
like uh grooming
trigger warning grooming and james
charles it's synonymous now
seriously james charles triggers me
oh we'll trigger warning james charles
we have to give him james
at the beginning of the episode he
should probably do trigger points on the
17th
uh james charles snapped me on snapchat
he added me back
because i had snapped him a while ago
just like a fan to influence her
conversation
i was excited because he's my biggest
influence
influencer-wise and he i've always
looked up to him so i was excited to get
his message back
i don't have a lot of time so i'm going
to post proof of it right now this is
the notification that i got when he
snapchatted me first
and just for further proof he deleted
the chat i don't know what he deleted
but that's me opening his snapchat
i went into the bathroom and i guess he
saw the bathroom light
so he started making the conversation
very sexual and made me really
uncomfortable and i'll post some of the
stuff that he sent me now you can't see
it because it's blurry because i took it
on my ipad because i didn't want him to
see that i screenshotted it
but i'll post it right now
wait let me read by the way what a creep
he's sending this photo of himself to a
16 year old
fan here he says he was pleasuring
himself the whole time
and wanted nude pictures of my body for
his pleasure
that is
started making the conversation very
sexual and made me really uncomfortable
and i'll post some of the stuff that he
sent me now you can't see it because
it's blurry because i took it on my ipad
because i didn't want him to see that i
screenshotted it
but i'll post it right now okay first of
all
what is wrong with you dude he goes he
goes pause now
i've been trying i've been trying to
pause it you made it two
little frames with peace and love thank
you for coming forward though
he says he said i bet you can make me
finish by just flexing and showing off
your hair
body hair haha without even taking your
dick out
yeah holy [ __ ] pink is body hair
i actually didn't read this oh really
yeah but there's a lot of people that
have come out with like
he want armpit pictures wait guys he
this is it this is a 16 year old
let's get it let's go get them who oh
we're like the swat team i don't know we
got him
we're like dog the body hunter and beth
r.i.p we got him he's asking for nudes
from a six-year-old where's chris hansen
ladies and gentlemen we got him have a
seat right over here
james i mean what the [ __ ] what's the
question what's the question
what are we waiting i guess he has to
okay so update to this this guy like
seven minutes or seven minutes prior to
us filming said that he was going
to the police today oh no
i don't know because he also yeah he
should
at this point i think people are scared
they don't think anything's going to be
done or you know people have money so
they're scared to go
dude where's chris hanson doing an
alicia documentary that no one cares
about like you should probably be
focusing on
bro james charles is a way bigger scoop
all right i'll be james charlotte would
you
james we could just have that put your
ass sit right here
do we get christy it's not chris
answered me on the show he did a whole
documentary on youtube yeah
he's desperate i always got weird vibes
from christmastime
he stopped a lot of rounders well i feel
i don't know that his heart was in it
for the right reasons you know what i
mean i think
if it's not at least some good was done
there's predators being stopped
online who else is gonna take that much
medication to do it
honestly that was good i'm mixed on
chris
yeah the nissan stuff was a little i
didn't even go with them
anyway um let's keep watching
yeah chris hanson get him i'm pro chris
han whatever it takes bro i just want to
see
swat team coming down from the roof
roof everywhere lasers and [ __ ]
and james rose hello james charles was
like
sister snap hi sisters to the swat team
what does happen though in this
situation does he get arrested does he
get a slap on the wrist is he gonna find
because this is what the
it depends he said um going
look yeah you're a predator bro he said
um
16 year old boy who accused james
charles sexting him last week is going
to the police he later said in a video
the police are going through his phone
currently
not i love how meanwhile james charles
is like good morning sisters
like literally being like what was the
thing he said somebody like something so
crazy like
i don't know he's just like well this is
pretty crazy right here i miss sundays
okay okay you're gonna miss a lot of
sundays where you're going
there's like a really big issue with
this this is not okay
he's like yeah he's like dudes tonight
let's keep going like
and he's 16 like it's so so
let's go after that and i'll post them
now
you dudes okay oh let's stop i was
getting
sent me to my radio yes okay they were
body shaking
got it yeah definitely oh don't send to
miners yes
yes he's sending it to miners
unsolicited it's okay to body shame
predators
okay you did a whole 180 on that one
quick okay if you're like
as long as you're not body [ __ ] okay
there's body shaming yeah if you're
being disgusting to children you should
be body shamed and
more um can i body shame james yeah i
mean
he's just got a big fake ass he just
looks like a [ __ ] creep
and by the way you seen his outfit at
coachella everyone's like oh queen go
off i was like no that's a [ __ ]
predator yeah don't be showing everyone
you're asking
that goes for girls and guys like that's
a little much to show everybody
please see you in jail bye and on
instagram too one thing to be at
coachella with it but then on instagram
showing all your followers like it's
just like a lot
no safe for work not safe for work 18
plus caption on it
right not safe for life more like
right right he's a grown man
and then he proceeds to say oh about
even get to see the
yeah meaning my body and after telling
him like no like i'm not going to send
it to you he kept on asking for pictures
and videos of
body hair and reflecting body hair he
proceeded to ask to facetime me which i
then
said no to and then i asked why and this
is what he said
jesus christ
i don't know what he said just
watch you sh just watch you show off and
look hot and
[ __ ] ha ha it's his shoulder
he says he wants no
it's sad to say that i can't even look
up my biggest influence the same again
i've heard multiple stories about him
doing this to people but you know yeah
that's it
but then so now of course that's like a
slam dunk like okay bye chris hanson
step in have a seat
here's what he responded
which is of course the most pathetic
victim blaming bullsh not taking
accountability [ __ ]
off so much oh my god i hate i hate it
okay so he says
first of all don't you dare put a
trigger warning you're the [ __ ] you are
the trigger
charles you need to put trigger warning
james charles on your twitter handle
also the note apologies is so oh my god
he can go on tick tock
and say all these things about me but
like he can't talk one tick tock and say
like hey
take accountability for sending news to
a 16 year old or put a sign on here
i'm a predator like you don't you you're
gonna kind of know like james charles
should be forced to introduce
himself to all of his neighbors as a sex
criminal for sure oh for sure but that's
i don't know how that's not even a thing
how he doesn't have to register how's
that not already one well here let's
read his apologies that's crazy there's
a video going around of me on tick tock
and twitter of a guy calling me
first of all a guy he's 16 years old
let's not even try to pretend like he's
older child a child a boy
calling me a groomer and i want to
address it right away the accusation
that i have groomed this person is
completely false
last week i came across someone on my
instagram explore page
this was last week yeah okay listen how
creepy this is
last week yeah actually this was like so
long ago like it lasted a week
listening sorry he did this a week ago
listen how creepy this is
oh my god he came across someone on his
explore page
he clicked his profile saw that he
followed him
and then he added him to snapchat like
if you're not trying to [ __ ] creep on
this guy
and by the way and by the way in his bio
i think it was snapchat or instagram
they show that it says he's 16.
no yeah james is like sick like he's
sick in the head so he's literally
creeping on this guy and by the way yeah
a lot of people follow you're really
popular so
like what were you what were you explain
to me james charles were you just
following this 16 year old boy just
because
i just wanted to check in with one of my
fans
and see how their life is is that how he
was like
like yeah he said he says
i uh he says last week i came across
someone on my instagram explorer page
saw he followed me and added him on
snapchat
right like that is like textbook bye
you're creeping on a six-year-old the
way like guy
like but it's even weirder because like
that person's not even like reaching out
to james like in a fan way like james
yeah yeah he initiates he's initiating
it
so he says the next morning i woke up
into several snaps from the person being
excited i had him back
of course saying he loved me and also
lewd photos of himself in the shower i
asked how old he was right away and he
told me he was 18.
so i started flirting back and the
excitement of meeting someone i thought
could be
potentially great i didn't ask for a
copy of his idea or password about any
situation you're in where you need to be
asking for a copy of id and password
is means that you [ __ ] up already yeah
like don't
don't go further so we act so surprised
that the guy responded it's like you
literally went
from instagram to snapchat
the one platform that's basically made
for predators
yeah literally the creep on fans yeah
followed him
and then you're shocked that he was that
he answered back to you
that's so weird and but he's like
someone who could potentially be great
you're on snapchat oh yeah
yeah oh he's looking to i thought i was
gonna marry the guy
in the excitement of meeting someone
yada yada i didn't ask for id
it's now clear based on the video he
uploaded he was taking photos of me with
another device
and held had an ulterior motive from the
beginning [ __ ] you followed him
how long how are you going to accuse him
of having an ulterior motive
he's one of like 20 million people that
follows you he's just sitting by his
[ __ ] bedway well james charles is
gonna
follow me back any second now you
followed him you [ __ ] creep liar
[ __ ] predator [ __ ] you i hate him i
hate him because the fact that he's even
trying to frame it like he had ulterior
motive from the beginning
this literally doesn't make any sense
dude you followed him on instagram and
snapchat
you pathetic predator [ __ ] oh my god
knowing knowing this kid is okay
he looks young i haven't i'll show you a
photo after i'm done reading this it
says he's 16 in his profile
yeah it's also not hard like if you're
doing that amount of research where they
found a snapchat on instagram like you
could find his age birthday or something
or let's say you don't know his age for
sure
but you but you could definitely see
he's young so let's just
play it on the same side and not start
sending news to someone who
might be 18 and might be 17 and a half
might be
you creepy [ __ ] oh
yeah even if someone sent me news like a
guy to a girl like it's just like
ew just like calm down for a second i
love this thing about ulterior motives
like i'm sorry dude if anyone had
ulterior motives it was you trying to
act like you were interested in this
family really all you wanted to do was
[ __ ]
beat off to a child you [ __ ] yeah that's
a mess up that's
ulterior motives [ __ ] you dude chris
hanson step in
chris hanson kick this motherfucker's
door down throw smoke
throw a flashbang block this
[ __ ] chris hansen now
i'm team whoever is calling in the swat
team on him may just police i don't know
if the swat team needs to be involved
i want smoke grenades and flashlights
you don't want that you don't want it i
want flashbangs on this [ __ ]
hey dan why is there an image that says
defamation on your screen
were you trying to send me a message
i'm gonna have like 10 defamation
lawsuits after this episode
with peace and love no nothing i'm
saying is untrue
later in the day he said so anyway later
in the day
later in the day he said a few things
that made me question the validity of
his original age answer
and i asked him to convert his age again
he admitted he was 16.
i told him i was really uncomfortable
and apologized for flirting but he
insisted on continuing talking of course
it's his fault this conversation is
taking place
saying it would be our little secret
he's a fan of mine and would never tell
anyone oh well he's 16 gyms so maybe you
shouldn't even mention anything he said
it's all your [ __ ] fault
i told him i was wasn't okay with this
he started getting upset and at this
point i unfriended him
we haven't spoken since i'm not victim
blaming him yes you are i'm
or victimizing myself yes you are simply
sharing what happened
and what happened was not okay after
false allegations like this in the past
are not false you admit that it's true
i would never knowingly engage with
anyone under age yeah knowingly it's
easy to unknowingly do it when you don't
ask or look or do any due diligence at
all
and put my life on the line for a few
snapshots because of situations like
this
instead of taking someone's word for it
i now will
ask to see the idea of passport if every
guy have a conversation with
so his conversation either his pledge is
not to stop
yeah it's just to ask for id you know
alphabet it's just that ask for photo id
i'm sorry dude but you are a danger to
society and i say that
with peace and love and he's not even
taking like a sabbatical like he's not
even like crystallia where he's like i'm
gonna like disappear for a few months
and maybe like
exactly yeah he's like you would think
he would like take a moment to reflect
but he's like um this guy's a [ __ ]
liar
and let me pull up can you see my phone
dancing well these people think they're
in vince literally his latest tweet is
good morning with sunshine
sun don't shine in a prison cell might
enjoy your last few good mornings
outside of prison i'm writing that
enjoying your last few good mornings
i love it uh enjoying
your last few good mornings outside of
prison
does that make sense is that good
enjoying your last few good mornings
before you go to prison or outside of
prison
yeah thank you enjoying your last few
good mornings before going to prison
and i'll do a sun emoji like he did he
should i don't understand i don't
understand how this is like not a crime
because
it's online i'm so confused enjoying
your last few good mornings before going
to prison tweet
dude i'm like this show has turned me
full mask off
just full on yeah
it's crazy i had an incident happen
in um middle school where a teacher like
groped my boobs all the time when we
would do like heads down seven up
and so when i finally went to the
principal about it he told the principal
well she's been wearing water bra so she
like she's been asking for it like it's
been teasing me
and the principal's like have you been
wearing water bras i'm like yeah what
and the principal was like receptive to
that argument he's like have you been
wearing waterproof i'm like yeah he goes
okay well let's not wear water broth to
school and like
that was my fault because i wore water
bra
i mean there was like more like that
dude this world is so [ __ ] crazy
what is a water bra a water problem was
it was my mom's it was a bra that it was
like
you fill it with water no it already had
the water in the bra was very heavy
and you were wearing those at what age
like 12 because i had uneven boobs so i
was trying to even my boobs
out for real and he and he said he would
come feel it all the time
because we play that game like heads
down seven up whatever and he had to
like put your head down or when you were
done the test but whatever and so he'd
come around like always like groping
whatever
and so i finally he did get arrested
this guy actually did get arrested but
um later on but me they were like well
she wears a waterproof
and then the second time that happened
uh it was a teacher and another teacher
a different teacher
and he's like well she told me she liked
the movie taxi driver so like or cape
fear i'm sorry cape fear he's like so i
just put my thumb in her mouth to suck
it
anyways it's just it's a lot but but my
trigger and i laugh because it's so
uncomfortable
my trigger is this kind of stuff so
[ __ ] up but when they say this
well they wanted it and people are like
oh well did you do that did you say you
like the movie cape fear then yeah
grown men should stick their thumb in
your mouth so you could suck it dude
the principal literally was like okay
well the principal didn't say anything
the second time it was the first time
that happened no but the fact that
they're receptive to that argument
no like literally is is blowing my mind
yeah and we're [ __ ] i think that's why
i didn't have friends because i think
they like knew like they saw my teacher
like
grabbing me and i was like okay i'm
sorry that happened
that's really unacceptable crazy but
then when i wanted to tie that back into
james charles to him to say like
well he insisted that it would be our
little secret ends up like that's like
literally what like
like like molesters do like that's what
they say they're like well she
she wore this so like that that makes
sense why we wouldn't molest her or
whatever
it's crazy either child yeah no it's
regardless if it's so bad i'm a fan it's
our secret like he's 16 he's incapable
of making decisions like that's why
you're a minor because
exactly you can't blame him for
literally anything even if everything
you're saying is true
the fact of him saying he had ulterior
motive whatever the [ __ ] you
there's no blame you cannot say anything
or put any blame on him you're the
[ __ ] adult
here's his um here you can see on his
tick tock
profile it says 16. james lied in his
note app james said he added him
off his instagram but his insta doesn't
have his snap on it
james liked one of his viral tic tacs
and got his insta from his tick tock
bile
his tick tock bile clearly staged his
age of 16.
thank you detective but even this this
this kid looks like a kid so the fact
that he even wants to beat off and get
news to it it's like he
looks like a child yeah it's like you're
in a relationship with someone who looks
young 18 to look young like you're just
like looking for people who look
young as [ __ ] to like jerk off to like
there's something wrong with you
another interesting wrinkle is that
apparently the guy's original
video that was going viral on tick tock
the victim
said that uh it got removed from twitter
for posting
private details like i guess james's
text or something
and then deaf noodles we love definitely
we love jeff noodles i want to hire him
in front of me if we hire someone else
he's like too busy for us too popular i
said what do i got to pay him he's
already doing all the work for fruit
yeah but we could get more exclusive
like he could just be here on the second
like just be like
i love death noodles though anyway shout
out he's got the best drama news ever
and
up to date he's the king yeah but anyway
he's thinking
um he's he got a 12 hour suspension for
post reposting the video
yeah oh [ __ ] so i don't understand what
is this like
crazy protection of james like this guy
is saying
he was preyed upon by james why
all of a sudden with everything going on
in the world twitter take putting the
foot down on this james charles video
just strike me as very odd like yeah
there's like beheadings on twitter
like that's okay but like james no i
mean
was the one that got removed with james
nudes in it
yeah blurred
maybe that like sharing but you know but
what proof can
he i feel like it's an important thing
like he's showing proof like what is he
supposed to do
yeah probably like he can't share
people's nudes then a bunch of people
have been coming forward
after this so this is all going on the
past few days he was accused of a second
underage boy of allegedly having
inappropriate interactions with a 17
year old
a third person came forward apparently
they have receipts too
james uh inappropriate sexual
interaction with the fan they alleged
james was very demanding and pressured
them there's videos and stuff but like
honestly you guys know that it's all
like come on the pattern's there right
how did he um
uh oh this one just happened dude i saw
this on reddit
i wanted you to see this okay you got it
and i'm not sure why nobody's talking
about this y'all know this creator right
i don't think you do but he's 16 years
old and he he's like really tall he's 6
11.
james charles commented under one of his
video putting ceo of heights
16 year old commented back with buen
venito's james and james said
trying to dm you but it won't work check
ig lol
obviously all the comments started going
off like what the heck is going on
telling him that he's 15
which obviously anyone with a brain can
see in his bio but james responded with
i love that i think anyways that comment
is no longer there
i don't know if that's like off-putting
to anyone else maybe he just
yeah when was that when was the comment
i mean i don't know this was posted a
day
ago but i don't know when i could
probably see the date in the video
so he's hitting on public on 15 16 year
olds publicly on tick tock saying dm me
wow i can't see the date but these
people are like
something they're like sick like he's
doing this publicly like
he's gloating that he's getting away
with it like it's insane like that like
he's sick in the head for real like
there's something like
wrong well what's sick to me is that
in this era of me too where literally
nobody's getting away with anything
anymore
james charles who has proven to be a
prolific predator
is not being held accountable in the
slightest bit not only that but he has
partnerships with huge brands
huge celebrities he doesn't get if it if
there's
anything from this it just means that
people don't give a [ __ ] when the
victim's a man
specifically oh yeah oh yeah right right
exactly yeah with these guys i mean
i mean if you in the midst of this whole
me too thing it's like and the same
thing goes
for david the victim is seth no then
there's no [ __ ] accountability
because if the victim's a man then
nobody [ __ ] cares
that's the pattern i'm seeing here of
course yeah it's really odd
it's okay let's put let's say chris
delia crystalia is doing
what crystalia did is identical to what
james charles is doing
right identical right crystalia's life
was ruined
he was dropped by everyone by his agency
he was even [ __ ] finished a movie on
netflix that they kicked him out and
re-shot with a new character okay
james charles is working with all those
same people
top brand celebrities and and no you
know what i mean
no i know yeah you're right that's it's
so true it's just so
it's [ __ ] up or the harvey weinstein
thing it's like you know
with all those stories and it's like
david dobrik has like admitted to all
this stuff and still yeah it's really
it's really crazy
wow i don't know i don't know and it's
like like what is gonna be done i mean i
don't i
these people just can't continue it's
crazy it's they just continue to be them
i guess just talking about it and
hopefully people start seeing the light
i mean it's kind of like the harvey
weinstein remember when courtney loves
like stay away from her auntie and i was
like okay crazy courtney love and then
like all of a sudden like 10 years later
everyone's like oh maybe she was right
well i don't know if we'd need like a me
too for like men victims because it
seems like men are not a part of the me
too thing you know what i mean
right it's like and the women needed to
me too because
they for obvious reasons right yeah but
i feel like men are not
these guys are not getting any justice
or respect from anybody but specifically
like this is
also like the straight seth with
straight jason like that one didn't get
any news but this james charles stuff
it's like it's kind of crazy i guess
because i think it's like
funny and a joke because they're two
straight men kissing i don't know it's
like weird how that got like zero
attraction when it's like
dude seth's life was severely
severely disrupted and and
[ __ ] up and trauma traumatized from
this so it's like
the trauma is the same right
there's more james stuff you want to see
like on impulsive
by the way here let me show this
impulsive guys great interviewers by the
way
are you being serious no okay here
so the thing is for me i'm 21 but like i
said i have the mentality of a 40 year
old yeah
so for me like i'm much more mentally
and emotionally mature than a lot of
people
you think you have the mentality of a
four-year-old you think you're more bro
you think you're more mature
bro what the [ __ ] which is also extra
creepy you think you have the mentality
of a five-year-old but you want to do
this okay jimmy savelle or whatever
[ __ ] who's that i was james he's like a
prolific english
pedophile oh great guy
he's english just say english that says
it all about it
really dan when do you hate when did you
start hating like english people so much
like i'm much more mentally and
emotionally mature than a lot of people
my age
i'm not physically attracted to older
guys which sucks like i would
date like the absolute youngest like 18
19 that looks a little bit older um
there was another clip where he's nice
to interview guy he's like so um
i'm not attracted to older men i just
want to date the
youngest possible legal life and logan
paul is like
yeah interesting he's like no no no back
the [ __ ] up
say what the emotional charity of a 40
year old according to you
which means you want to manipulate and
power play an 18 year old if you think
you're 40
you want like that doesn't make any
sense find another person your age that
has that mental capacity as you
um anyway james is a predator yada yada
yada there dude there's so much how
we've been going for so long so what
happens then
three hours for real holy boy 3 30 right
now
what happened sorry i'm taking my hat
off
we should have been eating ramen or i
should be eating ramen you know
here take a bite really take a bite of
my hair it's wrong did i taste it
or was it weird i wouldn't i mean it's
just chemicals
i guarantee it doesn't taste like ramen
okay
oh it's good i like hairspray you want
to spray in it yeah
it's heavy it's good it tastes sugary
hairspray is just why did you lick my
hair just now
i know but i just i feel like i feel
like i'm gonna have to do an exposed
video on you know
everyone here can attest that's my
that's why i bring bows everywhere so
people
can't be like oh i didn't say this i'd
be like no he was in there but you know
it doesn't taste like ramen
no i i like these hairspray so i was
curious to tell you what hairspray and
gel taste like together i used to put
hair spray on my tongue just to get high
whoa that's some freaky [ __ ]
what were you saying before you tasted
my hair
uh oh small dick energy yeah he has that
for sure so there's other things i don't
know if we could end it but like bar
stool where
they were dude there's too much like who
cares about barstool
oh oh they were watching your only fans
and laughing and stuff
yeah but to be fair you did that too to
me right but
that's true i said that to be fair i did
have done that
but like we were having a spat and i
don't understand why
they were just gathering around laughing
and they posted it like there's no
reason for it
i sent them to you unsolicited they
seeked it out and paid for it so it's a
little different
you were like no i don't want this
disgusting stop it
they were more like i'm gonna pay for
this and then also shane i hate those
like why didn't they do these things
like pick me girls where those girls are
like 30 years old and they're trying to
be cool in office big oh my god
don't throw up are you gonna throw up oh
my god like i hate girls like that so
much and those were all pink meat girls
didn't then dave horner like pick me
girls
pick me up what does that mean it's um
the girls that try and be like like pick
me pick me
yeah yeah like you know like oh like you
know i just want to have a beer with the
boys like i don't even do girl stuff
you know like those kind of girls pissy
girls although i'm a pick me girl i just
bought a trans
am it came today so we were doing a
little like tour and i was just like i
guess got a muscle car like that
yeah very pick me like you know i have a
muscle car now so
it sounds like you can't decide if you
want to be one or if you don't if you
hate my life that is the multiple
personalities in me i don't even know
what's coming out
seriously sometimes i don't know like
i've been hearing voices in my head
lately and i'm just like oh are those
me or those something else are those
demons sometimes i hear demons at night
at like the 4 a.m i know it's past the
witching hour which is 3am but at 4am i
hear the demon voices and i'm like oh my
god
that's a lot to unpack you hear i know
you keep saying that you're like
you're think you're going skits over i
don't know you don't seem schizo to me i
think i'm just like
really early on not dear dude you're
in your 30s this stuff happens earlier
in life that's not true
i talked to a specialist about it and
they're like no you can develop
schizophrenia at like 70.
it's sometimes it's suppressed with my
other [ __ ] that's going on in my head
and sometimes i suppress it but don't
you think like with everything you've
been through
by the way i'm not trying i'm trying to
comfort you because i really don't think
you have schizophrenia i'm not trying to
dismiss your concerns right no it's just
definitely voices i don't know if it's
getting anything well the thing is
voices and stray thoughts and intrusive
thoughts can be the result of a lot of
different stuff you know they just get
so much stronger
like i used to like think things but now
i'm like oh i'm hearing like i would
talk to a
person at the register i'm like oh what
was that and then like i didn't say
anything because i literally think the
voice was talking
to me and i was like what like what did
it like for example what does it say
sometimes voices are just like very
casual it's like oh like you know it
sounds so stupid but like your zipper is
undone and i was like oh my god
something random yeah like oh don't
forget your purse but sometimes the
demon voices
will be like hey there's a window jump
out of it
i don't like the demon voices yeah but
that's why it's calming to actually
since like i met like emojis they have
like calm down a bit
because when someone's like next to me
it brings me back to reality where and i
tell him this because i used to get
anxious with him sleeping next to me i'd
be like oh my god what is that because
voices would be like who's this person
get this person out of your bed like all
of a sudden i used to have anxious i
don't have that anymore
now it's like when i see him it's like
i'm back in reality where i'm just like
oh okay everything's okay
are you talk are you talking to someone
about these issues you are okay good
how often once a week just be a zoom
it's the same guy he's not really like
he referred me to someone that talks
about voices but i haven't really i
don't talk to that person once this is
someone else that doesn't really like
specialize in that but
okay as long as you're talking to
someone i think it's good yeah
it's scary it sucks
yeah i mean it seems stressful but like
i i just
i don't know what it you should but get
the help you need you know what i mean
yeah yeah
but
that's i'm sorry that's happening i mean
that's weird yeah i don't like it
i'm not really sure but i think you'll
be okay i mean you don't strike because
people when they're like i think
schizophrenics have certain
characteristics like where they
for example can't make eye contact right
you don't have that issue
no i'm totally like functioning and like
always like that and like they subside
like they do like i don't know i get in
like moods where it's like if i'm like
low energy it's like something
happening but it doesn't happen too
frequently but less frequently than it
was like last summer it was really you
feel like detached from reality when it
happens
yes you do yes and no i know where i'm
at it's not like blacking out like i
know where i'm at but i'm like hearing
the voices
right mm-hmm i guess what i mean is do
you feel like
when you're experiencing these voices
you know that
you know that somebody's not really
talking to you right no i literally will
ask people like oh
what did you say like i've asked that
twice now to people where i'm like oh
did you say something like no
or like what about the demon voice i
mean the demon voices happen in the
morning like when i'm up early
but you know it's not real there's not
really a demon i tell myself that but
like it doesn't click it doesn't click
right away
right so i will like look at the window
and it'll be like jump out i'm gonna
i'll go to the window and like no this
isn't real
and then i'm like oh like okay don't
jump out like
yeah the windstorms lately i feel like
there's some bars on those windows
well it's fine
well i just want you to be i'm just you
know yeah i don't like that
but i but yeah i mean it sounds like
you're talking to someone
just you know take care of yourself yeah
thank you
i will i mean if anything happened to
you i don't know what i'd do without
this show i mean it's just
that'd be a sick episode they're alright
trisha for sure
get so many views i'd rather keep you
alive you were my last real friend you
know what i mean they'll be like oh
ethan like really
i was like gave her some comfort out of
her life oh my god
no i'd rather keep you alive i can make
way more money from you alive than that
i don't know that episode would probably
be sick honey and
adam and eve sponsored by do you think i
could get sponsors on your postmortem
oh they're they'll [ __ ] they want
they'll milk your ass to the grave
i love it get the coin bury me with one
of those vibrators
that's a good that's a good lyric
barrier vibrators
yo i wonder if you could sell space on
your tombstone to adam and eve that's a
good point that's so funny
like just adamandeve.com trish like how
much to get paid up front
to put that on your tombstone because
you know you're you are kind of an icon
people will go to your to your
tombstone and they'd be like oh trish
who collects the revenue you well if
you're married to moses
you want me to i'll take the money no i
should probably get to my mom oh yeah
give it to your mom my sister
wouldn't that be unless you hire a teddy
fresh so she can like support
oh so if i hire her i get the money hmm
interesting let me crunch the numbers
i better give her the money i should i
love that we're monetizing your suicide
right now
no it's not me can i just say for the
record it's not me it really will be the
demons i swear i don't wanna i don't
wanna no i don't wanna no this is not
funny
this is not funny i don't like it i
don't want to die i'm telling everybody
right now i don't want to die
like literally don't want to die i
really like my life right now you better
no stop stop i don't like it i don't
like joking about it i'm not joking i'm
telling you no i know
i know i know no i don't want you to you
know what happens is when people do die
like anna nicole not to bring her up or
whatever but like
like when they die they say oh yep she
died of the monroe died
but they didn't they didn't and then
people like just
put that as like they killed themselves
like they didn't look into it they
weren't suicidal it was something else
look into it further is all i'm saying
well you think she was killed or was
like a mental thing
i don't know anything about her both of
them killed mel
just please take care of yourself i
don't want anything i just want you to
feel happy and healthy and
like yeah it's your voices right now and
that's the only thing that's like a
little bit scary but we're gonna
maybe any shock therapy like the uh no
no
no is it bad do we do not like shock why
for real i don't know anything that's
like one of those ancient
shits they used to that's not good you
don't think it's gonna like re-rewire me
they say if you only drink water for 30
days it rewires you that's why i did the
water fast and it didn't rewire my brain
well it didn't require my brain
come on water's not gonna rewire your
brain no that's true you talk to a
doctor
get some medicine look it up online i
know you had a bad experience with
medicine but i do think it's a problem
i'm not a psychiatrist obviously
but i do think it's important to try
keep trying to find something
if it's really disturbing like you know
what i mean um
medicine can work wonders if you find
the right one i know i know i'm not
against it i'm not against i just want
you to take i just you know what i mean
i
i can't i can't deal
you can't leave me in this world with
the black rolls royce
okay i'll stay alive at least for four
more years well my link to my list
i think we'll do this before until my
list expires
this conversation sucks way too dark
no i feel like i'm being an [ __ ]
because i'm trying to make light i'm
just no honestly sometimes you need
people to make light of situations
because it does feel so serious
i hope we're doing it for four years uh
i hope we're doing the show for four
years
yeah yes i love this show
um
[Laughter]
what you're the one that said it you
don't do it for four years oh you i know
where you see yourself in four years
like ellen you've left my ass behind
i'm in maybe more rosie o'donnell yeah
okay not because she's back because she
was on broadway
four years right she was on broadway and
she couldn't sing i could be
i don't plan on going anywhere i don't i
have no ambition to move on
i have because you're a baller i'm not
even sure
if i spend the amount of money you had
you did i'd be i'd be
dude you're crushing it you're sitting
in a custom-made denim suit
i made it goddamn no you definitely um
you definitely have given me uh image
rehabilitation on the show thank you
very much
patricia peters rehabilitation show aka
frenemies i didn't do anything except
just
i mean you did everything you just you
let you express yourself and we just
have a good time
the crepe show video was like i hated
ethan on his own i hated trisha but
together they're magic
all right i'll take it i'll take
whatever but why do people hate us so
much now they're like okay with us
that's a great question trisha i think
it's just because they didn't like our
content before so it's easier to hate
someone when you don't watch their
content
and you don't become invested in their
personality and you don't see them as
humans
so every time they [ __ ] up or do
something you just see that part and
you're like i [ __ ] hate them
they [ __ ] up again i hate them but
when they actually engage with the
content and they learn about like oh
this is who he is this is who she is
and they see like below just the flaws
that the
most a lot of people see then they go oh
i like them
because they're human beings and i see
them for that and not just the mistakes
they make
right you know
this was the coolest thing i've ever
gotten in my whole life you want to take
these i mean because i can't even eat
them maybe ela wants one
probably not they're so cute oh look how
they like vibrate
oh sorry vibrate it was like it was like
can i just say
right wrap it up i know we gotta wrap it
up uh james charles
i called this back in our front of me in
november is best friends with a 16 year
old girl
right if that was a straight man best
friends with a 16 year old i think a lot
of people would have a lot to say it
doesn't matter if they're gay
straight male female it's inappropriate
just like sia with freaking
uh what's her face maddie zigler it's
inappropriate it's grooming
you don't like go to red carpets with a
minor a child i don't care what
permission it is you don't go to red
carpet you don't have movie nights with
them
you're not besties with a 16 year old
like i called this out why
how people are surprised at this how is
sia not in jail she i don't know
thing what's the seal thing she like had
sleepovers with
maddie when she was like 15. wait are
you pro michael jackson or
anthony michael jackson because you
can't be like
anti-sia and then pro micah jackson you
can't do that
because michael jackson is like see ya
on [ __ ]
right i'm not pro i'm not from michael
jackson i'm not promising i'm
i'm pro victim okay and um
i don't i don't know any detail about
the seed thing i'll have to look into
that
i'll have to see into that
[Music]
right it's just crazy like how these
creators get away with stuff like
i i don't know if i shouldn't bring this
up all right yeah we we we played it all
out there you all make the [ __ ]
you all make the determination so who
have we canceled and who have we
have we canceled well we haven't really
canceled we haven't really done anything
we've tried we have done achieved
nothing on this show
shane was gone before you ever stepped
into the ring no
change was canceled the minute he stuck
he [ __ ] on his cap i cancelled him
again
i saw a clip of him saying that he lost
his kids he had like admitted i saw that
too
but he was he was saying to give the
full context when he was eight
he used to like molest his yeah
okay but what that's yeah i know yeah no
i agree
you can just because you're a kid that's
fine no i agree but i'm just saying i
don't want people to think that was
going on when he was like
20. he was like hey but he said i used
the most kids on my street
yeah like when he was eight he's like
aware that he did that i agree with you
it's
it's weird that's like the craziest
shock in the world
why are all these youtubers so crazy
like all these youtubers are so
crazy dude oh my gosh i think like a lot
of them were like victims of that stuff
like james obviously was with tati like
hanging out with tati when he was
underage and stuff like that i think
this happens it's like this like pattern
and they're just not getting the help
they needed to like not
be this person because like i had a lot
to happen to me i'm not like molesting
kids or anything
my head looks so small in this hat all
right let's wrap it up we've said it
we've done it all
you know what i mean what else is there
to say right there's nothing left
there's no stone left to in turn
there's only one there's a few peeps
left to beaten
i got it i got it you see it no no wait
wait
yeah can you get it moses i'll get it
i'll grab it it rolled kind of far
all right so once again guys we love
that's it that's all we've got so no
next week's going to be fun because
we're going to be doing jewish trivia
that is the worst teaser that is next
week we're doing a jewish show why
it's gonna be so funny holocaust we're
gonna be doing we're
gonna be we cover it all we're gonna be
doing jewish trivia
and we're gonna dress up as hasid's
orthodox jews
okay so insensitive i feel like you're
jewish i know it's fine but i feel like
something like
there's like the jew league or whatever
or like uh crate jew crazy is going to
be mad about it
do crazy can be mad but that's fine i'll
take on you crazy all day
what am i alaha aleja ali huh
yeah you ain't no alia i'm alia how are
you ali
i'm i'm alia i'm gonna go to israel and
live there
okay i didn't work for you did it you
didn't learn any hebrew they didn't
teach you [ __ ]
well i am a city i am an aliyah though
you're not
it's people i've moved to israel and i'm
i'm an israeli citizen you know i'm a
dual citizen i'm going to be a dual
citizen too maybe
i can't wait for drew cherry to crush
you in this i don't have to study i've
been studying my
all right all right all right if you
beat me then you are an aliyah
i will grant you that oh i already get
by the power vested me in the state of
israel i grant you the
passage of aliyah aliyah is one by the
way people are wondering what that is
that is wait you're not even jewish how
are you going to make aliyah
what do you mean convert oh my wow now
that's an
alia i'm converting doesn't alia mean
like journey or travel or something
yeah that's a [ __ ] journey it's when
jews
outside of israel want to move to israel
they can automatically through some
relatively easy process get uh israeli
citizenship and move to israel and i'm
sorry why can't i be a jew you're not
jewish
why do you
we all come from god yeah g dash d try
telling the rabbis that
so how am i also not a jew i came from
them
yeah the rap the right yeah well
well well you can you're welcome to make
that argument they will say no
i'm not the arbiter of these things
maybe if i win next week i can take that
to the ali obviously i will send a
certificate
that i'll say by the power vested in me
by his state of israel and god himself
i pledge trisha paytas an alia honorary
jew
yeah and i'll get it notarized and
everything
yeah that's the most important all right
all right
thanks for watching guys see you next
[Music]
week
[Music]
you